there's no time o clock hey y'all yeah
hey once again yeah here we are with
episode 195 only five weeks until
episode 200 which I still don't know
we're gonna do it yet well I we've kind
of decided it's gonna be a pretty big
show I can't believe we haven't covered
this one yet and I also really can't
believe that people are interested in
this one because this case is everywhere
you know I grew up with this case well
the weird thing about this is that well
somebody like requested it a few weeks
ago and I was like holy [ __ ] yeah I
don't think we've done that one yet and
then I found out that HBO was doing like
a docu-series about it which is
streaming right now and it seems like
it's kind of everywhere at the moment
Atlanta child murders yeah it's like
this is a really anna was on mine hunter
season two obviously last year which I
saw I haven't seen I will say like full
disclosure upfront that I haven't seen
the HBO series yet I did see season two
of mine hunter I saw the 2010 CNN to the
two-hour thing that they did on the
Atlanta child murders would Soledad
O'Brien where she interviewed Wayne
Williams and stuff and I even watched
there was a 1985 fictionalized like TV
movie it was like three parts
it was long it was like each part was
like an hour and a half or something so
it was like three was like [ __ ] six
hours and I remember how long it was and
it had like some big [ __ ] stars like
[ __ ] Morgan Freeman was in the [ __ ]
James Earl Jones was in the [ __ ]
Martin Sheen the dude from Andrew
Robinson I think his name is the dad
from Hellraiser he was in it it's like
everybody was in it it's not it was
fairly accurate but I think like some of
the lawyers complained that some of the
[ __ ] was inaccurate so they had to put
it like a disclaimer at the beginning
saying yes is it based on true story
because it was fictionalized
blah-dee-blah but it was pretty like in
depth and [ __ ] so I watched it
the whole thing I can't believe I
watched the whole thing and it wasn't
bad but you know there were some things
in there that I'm not sure about like
sure or not but yeah so I and and also
there was an American justice show about
it stuff so I watched all that as well
and I've read all the [ __ ] about so this
case I think it fascinates people
because well gosh a lot of reasons but
probably because one it's a [ __ ] ton of
victims you know somewhere between 28
and 30 usually are canonical most of
them were children under 15 there was
not a lot of investigation for a long
time because it took the police a long
time to link all the crimes which is
dumb because they were clearly very
similar and unusual for the time period
even though it was a high crime area but
these were like particularly unusual
crime so it was strange that it took
them a long time to link them and then
the fact that there still to this day
remains some controversy over whether
did the dude that is you know thought to
have committed some or all of them Wayne
Bertram Williams who is still in prison
whether he actually committed some of
the crimes all of the crimes most of the
crimes
none of the crimes that you'll get
people arguing all of those
possibilities so I think that that's why
it's still kind of like really
interesting to people plus like the
whole like cultural context of what was
going on like in the late 70s and early
80s winds were happening they were still
enraged there was a racial element to
this big time mantan it was black kids
being murdered and there was you know a
lot of people from the black community
that really thought this must be white
people doing it particularly the Klan
and there was some evidence to suggest
that because the FBI did actually
investigate a family that were Klan
affiliated and had had them under
surveillance and stuff like that so but
there was nothing there um well we will
get into that like a little bit later on
you did the thing the thing is though is
that it doesn't fit yeah
I'm gonna say it's a little early on in
the show to give my opinion I guess I'll
leave it to then but there's just a
certain kind of things that have to
happen in a serial murder there's
certain profiles that the murder has to
has to fulfill and Wayne Williams filled
the bill and when he was arrested they
stopped so yeah I definitely do think
I'm gonna say right from the outset I do
think that he committed some or most of
the murders because you know famously he
was only convicted for two and the two
people that he was convicted for killing
were adults they were not children but
they were like considered to be of the
same series however there were one or
two crimes in the series that I think
might have been someone else yeah that's
possible because they may not have been
a part of serial murder well might have
been that some kids were killed were
they ever found were they out where all
the bodies found um I believe they were
now it took like a long time for them to
find some new bodies but I believe all
of them okay I believe those were found
but there was one murder in particular
that I'm thinking of which was a girl
and so most of the victims were males
were boys there was a handful of them
that were in their 20s now the way that
the girl was killed in particular or the
way she was left the body was left
seemed to me like a particular signature
that did not fit and also I think there
was another murder that was very similar
to hers that was not included in the
canonical list for whatever reason I
think because the victim at that time
was considered too old I'll get into
that in a little while too so I think
maybe that was a different serial killer
yes killing those girls yeah kids were
being killed didn't necessarily mean
yeah didn't didn't mean it was all the
same person but you know we'll get into
the story Wayne Wayne Roberts we guess
yeah yeah Williams right yeah Wayne
Williams yeah Wayne Williams is gay yeah
well there's not a lot of evidence he
would have been killing girls killed
what they're attracted to
usually a didn't that's would he kill a
girl to get her out of the way to get to
a boy that's possible but the character
of the guy I feel like I'm getting ahead
of myself you are
the character of the guy was I don't
think he was that ruthless I just don't
I don't think he would kill the girl to
get to a boy don't yeah I kind of do
feel like it's very I'm not saying it's
impossible like we talked about this a
lot unlikely it's I think it's unlikely
for a serial killer he had his way yeah
they usually target a particular type
and he had his way to get his hands on
boys and he is that way and I think he I
don't any I don't think he was very
heavy-handed I think he used seduction
and money and promises for money for
mainly I think that's how he did it well
yeah well he had kind of um he had clout
actually well he a little well he
thought he did I thought he had kind of
like an up you know he had his anyway a
business and he had like he said he was
a music promoter and so which he was but
in a very that's all you need to get
your hands on him boy yes so he did have
a way of like procuring them I guess is
the way you could say it so even though
um you know like I said there is some
controversy over whether Wayne Williams
committed all of these crimes I do think
he committed definitely I think he
committed the ones that he was convicted
for which was just to like I said I do
think he committed the majority of the
particular crimes that are usually on
the list but there are a couple on there
that I think were maybe somebody else I
don't think the Klan had anything to do
with it because the Klan has a certain
signature and this ain't it yeah you
know no I'm no one's defending the Klan
because they did some horrible [ __ ]
around the sub to but it's just kind of
like I don't so long area yeah and it's
the wrong it's the wrong signature and
you know it I mean it's not it's not
hangings and it's the wrong target it's
you they're gonna go for somebody who's
older and there's gonna be fire involved
in ritual and there's gonna be hangings
involved and it's gonna be in a secluded
area it's not gonna be in it it's not
gonna be in an urban area yeah so like I
said you know the FBI did investigate
them and I'll get into that a little bit
later on but um you know what I mean so
so just from the outset like I said I
definitely do think that Wayne Williams
committed if not all of the twenty eight
to thirty canonical murders at least the
majority of them as much as he still
continues to
say that he's innocent I've seen like
numerous interviews with him and I'm not
really buying it I have to say
so we'll kind of get I want to get into
like his psychology and stuff like that
because I kind of found him a
fascinating person um you know not
enough like hey what a cool guy kind of
way but that's dub dude and it's like
I'm really weird like kind of
psychological thing going on so before
we get into it as usual we got a whole
bunch of shout outs this week um some of
the people we've already shouted out
like on our side track shows but like I
said I know a lot of people don't watch
those you know or you know just a random
Bureau wouldn't watch that so I do like
to save all the shout outs and like put
them on the main show
even if I've already done them so uh
again I would like to shout out and
please forgive me you didn't correct me
on Instagram that I pronounced your name
wrong when I showed you the side Trek
show so presume I pronounced it right um
but it's nil eh I guess no way who sent
us a very generous PayPal actually two
very generous PayPal donations yeah he
was the one that sent us one and then
said for good measure and then sent us a
note the amount again yeah thank you
very much also our patron Mary Ellen has
doubled her patreon support so thank you
very much Mary Ellen you rock yeah also
wanted to thank Sophie again for sending
us the movie psycho mania the the arrow
video blu-ray which has all the extras
on it we'll be doing a movie
retrospective on that and a bunch of
toys yes yes did we shout that out last
week I think we might have I think we
did like the the Duran Duran the vinyl
box yeah but she had sent us a yeah she
sent us another movie again now this
just happened today but why had um oh I
forgot what I got a letter from somebody
you gotta let it go yes for both of us
Brian to heaven no I didn't open it oh
you have a nobody and go get it and
there it is alright through editing
magic we have receive the letter I'm
just gonna go out there and I didn't
know if and we're actually gonna open
this on the show this is it first
yeah I've always thought about doing
like an unboxing show like oh yeah
should we read it is embarrassing oh my
goodness oh my goodness
thank you yes indeed what should we read
it Tommy Jenny I've been following your
show for a bit now and must say it's
amongst my favorite podcasts absolutely
love the organized chaos that's a good
word for what we did
maybe that we should change the name to
that also greatly appreciate the
sidetracks during this covin weirdness
they've been giving me something to look
forward to each day whilst getting ready
for work so thanks your essentials sway
also particularly enjoy Tom's military
stories my pops was in Korea around
roughly the same time USAF though so not
nearly as cool yes please
oh thank you so much that it's like so
so awesome wants to hear more about
Korea we should do we'll do that on the
side track sure okay for like for the
other show that we all right I'll to
show some pictures of Korea that I got
yeah okay and tell stories just like
Sena because you've got you've got a
whole bunch yeah I got a little bunch
though well I can just like put them
over that can edit it more okay like if
you you know people listen to the audio
podcast won't be able to like alright
well do that you guys miss out on a
bunch of crazy [ __ ] okay so one more
shout out that I had to do I just like
heard about today um I got contacted by
a fan of the show named at Basel who
sent me a PayPal donation oh did you see
that person's name yeah yes way that's
what it was yeah and they them in their
wife Jocelyn
they sent a PayPal donation and they
wanted us to shout out
Basil's mother-in-law which I guess
would be Jocelyn's mother wanted us to
say get well Nancy Swan who is
recovering from surgery at the moment
apparently they all listened to the show
together okay yeah and she would she's a
big fan of ours so it's like that's
pretty rad yeah I'm Rob MADtv there's a
little Korean character named Swan
remember her Miss Swan she was funny
what'd she look like would say did you
work and I like [ __ ] what kind of
storms at a candy store it's actually a
white woman whose dress who's dressed up
and couldn't purse
to make a Korean a Jamaa perfectly
perfect perfect perfect personation of a
Korean woman of a middle-aged Korean
woman I used to work you can see you can
see him on YouTube
yeah I remember you showing me was MADtv
right I think it was ad TV I saw this
one whose last name was Swan except we
have two ends not one alright so I think
that's all the shadows right like so
yeah okay can't we actually opened a
letter the show yeah we ever did that
case anybody asks I'm drinking salza
reposado tequila with what's Red Bull
yellow Edition like the tropical red box
yeah yeah splash of lemon yeah cuz
somebody asked a couple people have
asked in the YouTube comments it's like
hey can you say cuz I cuz I guess some
people are not watching the shows in
order like I just like assume because
we're usually doing the same thing not
always but what do I have you made it
that's actually a screwdriver it's
called a sunset it's just it's a
screwdriver this guy bought guys yes
guide vodka orange juice orange juice I
made homemade grenadine I made my own
grenadine cuz they're not there they're
not selling it right now you wanna hear
something weird if you guys have
listened to the sidetrack show we said
we went to the [ __ ] okay so we went to
the public's liquor store no grenadine
we went to the regular Publix also no
grenadine and then yesterday yeah
we went to Target right and the grocery
store and Target also no grenadine yeah
look they had everything else like all
the other mixers all the other stuff was
there no grenadine yeah you know to make
Grenadines very easy if you've got if
you're out in your location it's just
pomegranate seeds cooked down in sugar
with a little bit of water you add a
little bit of of vanilla extract you
want you can use imitation but I use the
real thing normally and what was the
other little thing vanilla and a little
bit 11 and that'll make grenadine yeah
it tastes pretty much my dinner I didn't
have enough pomegranate seeds though to
really get the color right so I
fortified it with a little bit
whole cranberries that I had frozen in
there that work to real close yeah real
close flavor but yeah I just I found it
very very weird that it's like you know
I think we mentioned on the show it's
like why was grenadine out in two places
now it's three places that we've been
yeah and that was all that was gone and
it actually tastes better than
store-bought grenadine but it doesn't
quite have the right color it doesn't it
doesn't say that cloud doesn't do that
cut it but gradient but the flavors
there
yeah it's me you know I don't know what
the hell artificial [ __ ] they put in
anything to like make it all pretty
Awana alright so I think we're done with
all the shoutouts then so let's get back
to talking about the Atlanta child
murders like I said well well we did a
fun show last week like with the
hauntings and everything so we had to
get back to the depressing [ __ ] sometime
so sorry about that but I know you guys
like the true crime stuff in in a way
it's like I know this is kind of messed
up to say I was just thinking about this
today because I was thinking about the
juxtaposition of like the fun paranormal
topics with like the depressing
true-crime topics but in a way like I
think reading about sure crime doesn't
bum me out as much as it would because
sometimes it makes me feel better
about like if I have a bad day or
something like that I'm like well
murdered Lisa [ __ ] didn't happen to me
you know ever so in a way it's kind of
like weirdly life-affirming as well as
like being really upsetting at the same
time I try to make them fun yeah by you
know bagging on it they're I mean
they're so fun it's like it's just that
I don't know I it's a hard like line to
walk between because you don't want like
people like victims families it's so
like that leads to get offended and [ __ ]
because it's like I would never like
make any fun of that like at their
expense or I never make fun of the
victims oh yeah if you wanted a damn
perpetrator you should make fun of the
killers yeah they're pathetic yeah
because that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] right
there it's like if you just if you take
them seriously and like make them out
into like some kind of monstrous
something that kind of plays into what
they want I kind of feel like yeah
they're pathetic [ __ ] losers mother
yeah I love them really oh yeah well if
they weren't they wouldn't be doing this
the only one that was kind of [ __ ]
half a damn man was the cop one that
they caught and then went and then that
[ __ ] was pathetic - it was his
name the other Hills the other night
stalker what was his name oh yeah the
real night stalker those but the first
at first oh my god I forgot his name
they just caught it yeah well they
caught him like a man I just totally had
a brain fart and I called it I feel like
I figured he was cop well the weird
thing about that in the policies as well
yeah Wayne Williams it's like a lot of
serial killers have cop fetishes yeah I
think it's because they want like they
like the feeling of like power control
stuff like that BTK had it a lot of them
are you know try to be in law
enforcement or what our study law
enforcement techniques or they in or
they can't hack it or something I got
cop wannabes yeah and so Wayne Williams
had that as well and he later on would
say like he trained with the CIA and all
this other crap yes like with Frank Dux
I'm afraid dr. [ __ ] Williams is an
a-number-one bullshitter and it's like
even before he got caught as as a
murderer
everybody that knew him pretty much said
the same thing even people don't liked
him said that he was a bullshitter I
mean he would give people his [ __ ]
resume like his job resume and stuff
like that and there was stuff in there
that obviously was not true I mean so he
was a Fanta cyst IRA let's put it that
way but yeah so as we said Atlanta child
murders uh you know either called the
Atlanta child murders sometimes called
the missing and missing and murdered
children whatever these were a series of
murders usually said to be between 20
and 30 murders that occurred between
1979 and 1981 all of the victims were
black almost all of them were children
almost all male there was one girl in
there I think this is one girl or maybe
two girls in there but I kind of feel
like maybe that was a different perp I
think that was a different serial killer
because it does happen that several
serial killers are operating in the same
area at the same time as horrifying as
that sounds we did a show a while back
about [ __ ]
London Ontario in the [ __ ] from the
60s to the 80s where they think there
were at least five serial killers
operating during that time period and I
was just writing about a few cases in
various parts of Canada like other parts
of Canada where they think there were
several serial killers targeting
prostitutes at around the same time so
it's not impossible it's unlikely but
it's not impossible
I do think Williams was rightly
convicted of you know the crimes and I
do think that he committed most of them
but there's a couple that I think we're
probably not him so let's go back to
1979 and we'll talk about they will kind
of go in order of the timeline of the
murders so mid nineteen seventy nine one
of the first victims is Edward Hope
Smith also known as Teddy and Alfred
Evans who was also known as Q that was
their nicknames these were both
fourteen-year-old boys now they
disappeared four days apart however they
found both their bodies on the same day
like in the same wooded area on July
28th of 1979 now Edward Smith had been
killed with a gunshot wound 22 caliber
in his upper back as you will see there
some of the some of the murders most of
them were strangulation or asphyxiation
which is what they say when they're like
well we think they were strangled but
we're not really sure could also cover
smothering however a few of the victims
were shot maybe there was just one that
was shot but a couple were were stabbed
so some have speculated that not that
Williams was innocent necessarily but
that maybe he wasn't working alone which
again that might be another possibility
so you know the well you know what I'm
gonna say what's that the ones that were
shot and stabbed were they bigger kids
than the ones that were suffocated know
pretty much all the kids of the
canonical list yeah were you know under
15 years old
they were usually pretty small like then
even the adults that were killed later
in the series were small they were
usually like short real short or they
were mentally handicapped in some way or
they were very slim or something else
that made them quote unquote childlike
which is why they you know associated
them with the same series it makes you
wonder if there was shot or stabbed
because they were trying to get away or
successfully getting away that's a
possibility sure yeah I mean the thing
about it is that it's not unheard of for
serial killers to alter their emmos
particularly maybe in their I mean if
this was early in the series maybe he
was still figuring it out
either it's more than one person cuz
it's separate crimes and you just put
him in a scene - I don't know if it was
separate crimes or not um because they
both they the kids most of these kids
knew each other they lived like it was a
very small area like they lived in the
same neighborhoods I think it was only
like a 12-block radius or something like
that and so it really does seem like the
kids were lured into a car and like I
said I'm not saying that Williams was
innocent but I'm also saying that there
might have been another person involved
like he might have had an accomplice
that never got caught or there might
have been another killer operating at
around the same time period whether they
knew about each other or not I don't
really know some people have also
speculated that there might have been
like your standard pedophile ring you
know that kind of thing has been put
forward as well whether wayne williams
was part of it or not they don't really
know but there are some stories later on
that some of the kids that were later
found you know got into different cars
than the ones that were seeing like
wayne williams had one particularly he
actually had two cars because he lived
with his parents and they had two cars
and sometimes he would use one of the
other but some of the kids were seen
getting into other cars however some of
those cars had two or three men in them
um one of whom may have been Wayne may
have been Wayne Williams and like I said
so it's possible
got accomplices as well you know there's
a lot of possibilities but like I said I
don't think he's innocent but I'm not
saying that he was the only one either
there was maybe other people doing the
same [ __ ] so September 4th the next
victim was also a 14 year old boy
Milton Harvey now he was actually going
to the bank to cash a check or to
deposit a check for his mom he was
riding a ten-speed bike it was yellow
and the bike was found a week later kind
of in a remote area of Atlanta however
his body was not found until November
was it yes uh yeah I think he was caused
all the way on the way back yeah um
actually by the time they found his body
because it was a couple months later he
was so decomposed that they could not
definitively say what the cause of death
was October 21st of 1979
Yussef Bell who was nine years old he
went to the store he was going to buy
some snuff for one of their neighbors
who's an older woman named EULA birdsong
he often like ran errands he you know
it's a lot of kids would do that the
neighborhood back in the 70s it's like
you give him a buck or something like
that and say hey go run and get me some
cigarettes or something so he went to do
that and like you said you know these
neighborhoods the stores and [ __ ] like
that were just like right there I mean
he was just gonna look across the street
or like down the block it's not like he
was going miles out of the way you know
what I mean it was just kind of like run
across the street and get me some [ __ ]
and then he was supposed to come back so
he goes so Yusef goes to the grocery
store now a witness said that she saw
him by the intersection of McDaniel and
Fulton streets getting into a blue car
and then he was never seen again
now his body was found November 8th
in an abandoned elementary school I
guess it was like a janitor in there he
was like cleaning the place or you know
somebody a caretaker something was in
there cleaning the place and found the
body I heard that it was like a couple
of
commentary's that I saw said that he was
like stuffed into like a concrete crack
like in the floor like he was like left
in there um he was still wearing the
brown shorts that he had been wearing
like when he left now he had walked to
the store barefoot they said that he
didn't put any shoes on because he was
just going down the street he was still
barefoot when he was found but somebody
had watched his feet which I thought was
very weird um also the shorts that he
had found like had masking tape on them
for whatever reason um he had actually
been bludgeoned to death well he hadn't
been bludgeoned to death but he'd been
hit in the head and then he'd been
strangled and that was the cause of
death now because he had been strangled
and some of the previous victims you
know Milton Harvey he was decomposed so
they didn't know exactly what the cause
of death was the earlier victims one of
them had been strangled and one of them
had been shot
so initially police did not link all of
these murders together even though it
should be said as I mentioned earlier
that this part of Atlanta was kind of a
high crime area at this time there had
actually been a couple of really
high-profile murders of like there was
one particular case that was like a
white doctor who was he was attending a
conference in Atlanta and he was shot by
two black robbers like in the course of
a robbery and it was like made national
news and show like that however this
type of child murder just like abducting
children and then their bodies being
found later strangled or whatever was
unusual um but initially police did not
link all of the cases you know I mean
even though there had been four at this
point now March of 1980 this is the
first female victim like I said I'm not
entirely sure this is considered like
one of the series but I'm not entirely
sure that Wayne Williams did this one
this to me sounds like a different
signature but you know I'm not an FBI
profiler so you know take it with a
grain of salt I'm just saying it just
sounds on weird to me so this was a 12
year old girl named angel Lanier
um she had left her house at 4 p.m. on
March 4th 1980 and she was last seen at
a friend's house she had gone on to her
friends to watch Sanford and sons
Sanford and Son and she disappeared
after like after leaving her friend's
house her body was found six days later
in a vacant lot
now she was wearing the same clothes she
had left home in however a pair of white
underwear that were not hers had been
stuffed into her mouth and her hands
were bound behind her pack back with
electrical cord she had also been
strangled so again this seemed like a
little bit cuz see some of the things
like she I don't remember if this one
was the one where she was tied to a tree
because some of them were tied to a tree
and to me that seems like a different
signature you know yeah it sounds like a
different person and Plus like I said
the fact that it was a girl it's weird
because they wouldn't say if she'd been
raped but Oh was she again 12 I think
she had been raped it almost sounds like
something other kids did to her wouldn't
surprise me if that might have been
fifteen sixteen fourteen-year-old boys
maybe did that to her well there was
another one that happened nine months
later that was very similar to this one
so I kind of think that maybe there was
another serial killer running around
little girls yeah but it's also not
unheard of AB little boys doing that to
girls I'm sure some serial killers have
killed girls you know I mean really
young ages yeah 13 14 years old they've
killed him they killed girls yeah yeah
it wouldn't shock me all right I'm just
saying I'm not sure if this I mean
there's a lot of kids in this area that
just a few years later ended up in
prisons doing life sentences in this
area these are rough neighborhoods yeah
they are so wouldn't surprise me if that
was actually some of her peers somebody
that was around her age did that yeah
possibly I'm just saying it's to me that
just seems like because the victim
profile is a little bit different yeah I
don't think idea two different killer I
mean yes she was abducted yes she was
strangled but as far as I can determine
none of the male victims the boys or the
men were sexually assaulted however I
believe that angel Lanier might have
been although they're very cagey about
saying that especially when it's like a
twelve-year-old girl I don't know if
it's because they are withholding
evidence because you know they want to
like keep things close to their vest so
in case somebody confesses that they
have like some information that you know
only the killer would know or if they
just don't like to publicize that I'm
not really sure I do suspect that she
was probably raped so you know you're
saying these boys weren't not that I
ever heard of they were just mostly just
strangled hmm which sounds it's very I
don't know it's just very weird maybe he
was making him give him a head sure
that's a possibility
that's possibility that's what I'm
thinking yeah yeah it might have been
something like that yeah so um March
11th which was the next one this was a
week after angel Lanier disappeared 11
year old Jeffrey Martin was also running
an errand for his mother and disappeared
now he wasn't found for almost a year
now someone came forward a girl came
forward and said that she saw him
getting into a car it was a blue car she
said with a light-skinned black man and
a dark-skinned black man that's what she
said um so the body was later found it
was 11 months after he had disappeared
he was found like out in there some
remote woods or something and the body
was too decomposed to determine what the
cause of death was may 18th of 1980 14
year-old Eric Middlebrooks he also
disappeared now this one was a little
bit weird and I'm not sure if this one
was the same killer or not either even
though this was a young boy he was
living in a foster home now apparently
what happened was that he got a phone
call and it was kind of late at night it
was like 10:30 at night or something
um he was known to kind of ride his bike
around and he had like little tool a
little tool kit that he would like take
with him
but cuz his bike broke down a lot and
heat so he could fix it so he gets a
phone call at 10:30 nobody knows who it
was and he said that he had to like go
out and do something and he hurried off
on his bike and took his little wrench
and stuff his little tools with him so
he could fix his bike in case he had to
and then the next day they found his
body lying next to his bike in like
there was like a bar and then it was
like a garage behind the bar they found
the body back there now
the bar were they found him was next
door to the Georgia Department of
offender rehabilitation it's not anymore
but it was at the time his pockets had
been turned inside out
he had like stab wounds on his arms and
his chest and he had been like beaten to
death essentially if they had beaten him
over the head now this one I'm not sure
was Wayne Williams because they pointed
out that this boy three weeks I believe
it was three weeks before he went
missing he had testified against three
other boys in a robbery case so this to
me almost sounds like the fact that he
got a phone call that late at night and
was like hey you need to come here that
[ __ ] because he apparently ran out the
house like his ass was on fire and got
on his bike and went somewhere and then
he didn't come back yeah they used to
really news all day so I kind of suspect
because Wayne Williams
you know his signature seemed to be that
he would abduct a kid and then dump them
like in a remote area he wouldn't leave
them like just in a building or
something usually you know I mean it was
like an abandoned building or it was
like out in the woods or in the river
later on tried to make him disappear as
much as he could yeah so this kid you
know I'm not certain but to me this
sounds and the fact that he died from
blunt force trauma to the head rather
than strangling to me sounds like maybe
more of revenge motivated killing yeah
and Wayne had a card he was intelligent
he would try to get the damn bodies out
of there yeah you know which that's the
same MO yeah all
the serial killers like Bundy would try
to do that I mean he tried to get him
away as far away from him as he could he
was trying to make the [ __ ] disappear
like it didn't happen but when they're
just dumping them locally in the area
that's usually like gang affiliation or
[ __ ] a little two-bit [ __ ] but come
personal stuff yeah to me that's what
this one seems like you know I'm not
saying that's good it's like no it's
just this somebody else did it's I don't
somebody a part of the series because
the mo was different and the way that
they where the body was left was
different because a lot of the guys
doing that that kind of [ __ ] and they
maybe they don't have a reliable car
yeah you know it's you know maybe they
were killed in that area so they had to
hide him clothes where they could drag
him yeah they like to eat oh they were
close in that area and hidden there but
Wayne had a car he could put a ball yeah
like something that something that um I
believe it was on the 2010 CNN
documentary um somebody that something
said somebody that something that
somebody said on that documentary who
was like a profiler or something like
that that kind of struck a chord was
like you know the vast majority of
murder victims are left where they're
killed yeah um you know because usually
it's like you know it's a fighter it's
in our groove there's a reason serial
killers tend to take them somewhere and
you dump them yeah they're just a plan
and they have a whole second support you
have a transportation system they can
get ahold of they have money because
they got to buy gas which means that
they have a job and they have income
it's different it's a different deal and
also it's totally premeditated
yeah and it's to fill us to fill a
sexual need that they have yeah it's
very different from say like a gang
killing or a retribution or killing or
something that happens during a fight
you know that's something like on the
spot yeah and not world well thought out
where they did where they're not really
planning they have like well you know
dude the [ __ ] throw down and all of a
sudden one thing happens and then the
dudes dead you're like oh [ __ ] what we
gonna do you know they can't get rid of
the Bison just hide him right there
let's get the [ __ ] out of here which is
usually I mean that happens a lot with
like domestic just be yeah yeah stuff
like that too it's like sometimes you
know they didn't necessarily mean to
kill the person it's just that [ __ ]
escalate and then they were like oh [ __ ]
now what do I do for a serial killer to
mr. as a serial killer on the radar he
has to at least commit three and he has
to do this to gratify a sexual motive
all right well in order to get three
under your belt you already have to have
a system and in order to have a system
you have to have a [ __ ] brain you
have to be able to think about it and
plan it out you know if you can't do
that then you'll never be a serial
killer you'll just be a spree killer
you'll get caught you know sorry
aspiring serial it's like a Darwin it's
like it's this Darwinism you know or
[ __ ] you know this it's a natural
selection a lot of them get knocked out
on their first homicide they never
become a serial killer because they get
caught because they get caught right
well yeah I mean the very reason that I
think that there's you know maybe not so
much anymore but there used to be a
common perception that serial killers
were like some kind of like criminal
geniuses or something know which might
have been from Silence of the Lambs like
yeah most of them are not but you have
to be a little bit above average
intelligence to not get caught for long
enough to become a serious actor because
you're if you're a dumbass you're gonna
get killed and you're gonna get like
caught immediately and you have to have
the means another that you have to have
transportation in order to have
transportation you have to have a job in
order to have a job you have to have
kind of like stable habits to where
you'll report on to work regularly now
not all of them were real good at daddy
Bundy who was one of them I guess you
could say one of the most prolific
serial killers was actually kind of
unreliable when it came to work yeah but
he did he could put on a front and he
could maintain if they make a facade of
being stable but I think he was out of
work a lot of times but I guess where
was his money coming from do you
remember was it coming from the victims
like doing like a vampire where you kill
them and then you take their money you
live off that I don't remember exactly
where either it's like it was he was
working for the Republican Party for a
while I know Danielle's wealthy family
maybe or an upper middle class family he
did have jobs off and on but I don't I
don't from what I remember the books
that I read of him he was getting fired
a lot or just not showing up to work
because you
I had to kill a [ __ ] have you been to
kill yeah I [ __ ] work man
I got it [ __ ] this head because he'd
have it hand damn ahead and [ __ ] this
work I got [ __ ] head [ __ ] this work
I'm gonna [ __ ] this head you'd have a
damn head in the damn refrigerator in a
bowl without can I [ __ ] resist that I
can't go to work when I got that in
there that's what that's weird dude man
[ __ ] weird dude can you imagine that
good weird don't process going through
your head yeah you know what I mean
well there was one guy I mean about sick
today because I just can't resist the
lure there's one guy that I don't
remember what his name was somebody in
the audience will remember who it is he
had a girl's head in a damn gym bag and
he would just [ __ ] totally rock up
with the idea him just walking around in
public with this girl's head in the bag
and nobody knew yeah and he was having
sex with the head and he was having sex
with the head up in his apartment and
then he put the head in the bag and he
was gonna go somewhere and he's walking
down the steps to where he lives in this
little [ __ ] boarding house and passes
a [ __ ] pretty girl in the hallway and
he's like man she doesn't even know I
got this head in a head and I got a head
in the bag and then he put clean you
don't even know he puts that the
passenger seat he drives around with her
and goes and does all kinds of [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] two dudes are weird bad they're
[ __ ] weird just goes to show how the
human brain can go yeah drastically
awry yeah yeah we didn't like think of
this [ __ ] who would think of this [ __ ]
I'm a horror writer who don't think of
this [ __ ] I mean sometimes I do but like
not like I want to do it I don't think
that was Bundy though it might have been
Bundy but I don't think it was they had
I mean that sounds like something so do
you but I think that there was I think
it was another one he was another yeah
I've read so many of them over the years
I read a lot of that ship and I was you
know Beck wouldn't host it might late
teens early 20s I was reading that kind
of stuff but then you kind of you kind
of get tired of it after a while you
don't just move on yeah but now we're
doing it for a living yeah [ __ ] weird
well I like I said I don't I find it
endless is but endlessly fascinating I'm
not sure why but the thing about Wayne
Williams though is that he had kind of I
don't know he had like a little bit of a
different motivation than Bundy but he
had the same kind of superiority come
I think he definitely thought that he
was smarter than everyone else he
thought he was smarter than the cops a
lot of serial killers seem to have an
inflated sense of their own intelligence
yes and Wayne Williams in particular and
he was very he had kind of a bitchiness
to him [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah well in the
state Wayne well the thing about him too
was that he had you know like many other
serial killers was kind of a law
enforcement groupie and so he had
studied law enforcement techniques and I
think that he thought that he was
smarter than the cops and that he would
be able to like beat lie-detector tests
and like do this and he wasn't gonna get
caught I do really feel like he thought
that he was smarter than everybody yeah
and I get that sense from like a lot of
serial killers a lot of times with these
serial killers is that there's they're
smarter than a lot of people that are
that surround them in their humble
[ __ ] environment yes so it's easy to
think he's smarter than everybody else
yeah everybody in the ward yeah yeah
that's not the situation it's just go
you're living in a humble ass
environment yeah yeah once you're out of
that environment there are a lot of
intelligent people that you're not
[ __ ] running into now in the case of
Bundy Bundy was very intelligent and he
got into [ __ ] college and he really
couldn't hack it in college yeah he
could only pretend to be intellectual
but he yeah deep down he knew he wasn't
and I think that kind of [ __ ] made
Bundy actually kind of lash out even
more you get a lot of them have massive
insecurity complex because you realized
that he wasn't really as good as these
other people yeah it came to it as he
thought he would be a was as good as he
wanted to be because I feel like a lot
of them maybe even if they don't were up
in like really [ __ ] up environments
cuz I don't think that Ted Bundy you
know for example and Wayne Williams his
upbringing was not I mean he grew up in
a very loving middle-class house of
Buddhist fan both his parents were
teachers they were lovely people and so
I think what ends up happening is that
it's very easy to
be superior do you know you live in like
kind of a small town or you live in a
place where there's not a lot of people
with ambition or there's not a lot so
it's very easy to think of yourself as
superior to them but then when you get
out in the wider world you go to college
you go to like a big city you go to
something like that and you kind of get
slapped down yeah cuz all of a sudden
you're common yeah all of a sudden
you're not smarter there's a lot of
people are smarter than you who are
better than you at a lot of things and I
think that that really [ __ ] with a lot
of their heads because the way they grow
up they kind of feel like they're better
than everyone and they find out that
that is not the case and I think that
that really happened in Wayne Williams
situation I think one of his main things
was that he was actually kind of I don't
want to say a prodigy because that might
be overstating the issue but I do think
that he was very ambitious as a child
um you know when he was a teenager he
had his own radius he that has done
radio station and all this other stuff
and I think that he really felt like he
was going places like as a music
promoter he was like trying to find the
next Jackson 5 and he thought he was
gonna be famous and then by the time
that he got into his early 20s he
realized that he was just a bullshitter
and that that wasn't gonna happen and
that maybe caused him to like [ __ ]
lash out because he started to feel some
resentment because he wasn't getting
what he thought he deserved I think that
might have been part of his issue I was
like a baby you know what I'm saying
because he definitely really did seem to
have that I'm better than everybody and
he was always like trying to inflate his
own ego he was trying to like blow
himself up into something that he wasn't
and everybody could see through it and I
think that he thought that people were
falling for it until he maybe got into
his early 20s when he began to realize
that oh maybe I kind of I'm not going
anywhere and I thought I was better than
everybody and I'm not and that made him
like really really angry one of the
things that I've always noticed out of
these guys and it's like a thread that
kind of connects them all as they are
there are all these guys that have
something that when you when you when
you look at them it's like there's
something missing in them every one of
them is a fake or a fraud yeah a good
example is remember they remember the
dude that was killing the cats
and don't from that don't [ __ ] with cats
don't [ __ ] with cats that dude yeah oh
man yatta luke mini otter I think is
what his name was if you watch videos of
that dude you can tell that that's just
an act
yeah that that that heat that that is
not a real person
yes that's exactly how a lot of drama
real killers come it comes across as a
facade that Sadhna that's not a real
perfect date but I also get the sense
that they think they're fooling people
yeah but they're not right it's almost
kind of like you're looking at a
sophisticated robot yeah and that when
you try to talk to that person it's like
you're talking to somebody who's
pretending and everything they do is
pretend it's like an alien and a skin -
yeah and you're like you and most people
can see this so they're kind of rapport
there are no that's not a good way to
say it most people can feel it
yeah really see they can sense it I'm
not right this even if you can't put
your finger right actly what it is so
there you you're kind of repelled by it
and I and I think that they know that
they're repulsive yeah they don't want
to accept it though but people are like
you know it's just like total total
superficial fake fake fake ass zero yeah
and Williams kind of came off like that
- I really like he was pretending yeah
he's pretending to be famous he's
pretending to be real important he's
pretending to be a genius but there's
really not a lot to there's nothing
really to him
yeah and I think deep down a lot of them
know that there's nothing to them and
that's kind of what causes the
disconnect between because you know it
lives in the hood but he's acting like
he's a millionaire yeah I mean he
actually did live in a better
neighborhood the game is actually middle
class
it was actually kind of lower upper
lower class lower middle class now
because like I said his parents were you
know their deaf teachers it was a kind
of you know he's acting like he's living
in Beverly [ __ ] Hill he really did
seem to and you know a lot of you know
people that knew him like I said even
people that were
that liked him said that he did kind of
look down on you know poor people but of
particularly poor black people you know
and kids we were just kind of hanging
the way they would hang around the
street corners like trying to make money
like you know hey this this is one kid
like one of the victims who was like who
would go in front of the grocery store
and try to sell like air fresheners for
cars and stuff like trying to make a
couple coins like to buy comic books or
whatever the [ __ ] kids buy and you know
I mean so it really did seem like he had
this superior attitude and some people I
don't know if this is true or not
because he has denied it but some people
have said that maybe one of the motives
for the crimes was that he was kind of
trying to he was kind of like set like
self-hating black person like he just he
hated the way like these little second
he just thought of them as like hood
rats yeah and he wanted to like
eliminate them oh I think he was
sexually attracted I think he was - I
think that's all I think it was
definitely like an element of that sure
that's all his he's just rationalizing
he's trying he's trying to rationalize
why he's screwing him and kill him
yeah yeah other just hood rats I can do
it I want with a bit really you know the
dude [ __ ] he's pedophile yes it really
does seem like that's kind of what he
just like well I can do what I want to
them because they're not
it's a shame in it's almost kind of like
you saw them as like subhuman yeah
exactly well it's the same thing that
you have these guys who go out and kill
hookers and they go well they're just
hookers I gotta kill him
yeah spread disease yeah dudes like that
they're just hookers yeah yeah they suck
that's what he's doing
yeah definitely just trying to make
himself feel better about why he's doing
it oh yeah big time yeah big time so
yeah so what you are we on 1980 hmm June
9th another kid Christopher Richardson
who was 12 years old he was actually
walking to the recreation center he was
gonna go swimming in the pool so he was
last seen walking towards the DeKalb
County Midway Recreation Center Midway
Park now they didn't find his body until
the following January so that was like
seven months later
weirdly he had been going to the pool
like with a particular pair of light
shorts on like blue shorts like it
swimming shorts when they found his body
there was a different pair of swimming
trunks on him
apparently that weren't his he spent a
time with him maybe it could be maybe
doing something it's almost kind of like
a date
where he's picking him up and tell him
he's gonna make him famous and how
talented they are hanging out he's
giving him alcohol there was corn
swimming and he's doing a whole little
date with him and then he has sex with
them and then he can't let him live
after that although he can't be taking
them anywhere publicly necessarily
because there weren't Nate there were
some witnesses that said they saw the
kids getting into cars with somebody
that looked like him but they I don't
think there are any accounts of him
being seen anywhere else with any of the
victims except for one of the adult ones
that happened later on and he's taking
him home yeah he might be well he lived
with his parents though so he might be
taking them some photos or his parents
were covering for him but I don't want
to say that because probably not you
know what I mean
he's made his parents really seemed like
lovely and I think they'd be stay we had
a place to take them
he must have I feel like he was doing
for all you know he's doing photo shoots
and stuff this is gonna be your for your
next album cover or some [ __ ] like that
you know well because they still have
like fliers that he used to post around
like on the area like how he was he was
recruiting for like I said he was trying
to make a band or so he said that was
supposed to be the next Jackson 5 it was
gonna be called Gemini yeah actually a
good name well that was his birth sign
that's actually a good name though Jim
if you got to put like a number on it
Gemini's 69 that's what you got it lay
him back you gotta think back to the
time they were talking about [ __ ]
1980 true I might have worked that would
ascend it was cool back then yeah back
to that would have worked yeah and you
had like some digital [ __ ] [ __ ] on
your album cover make it look real if I
tell users and whatnot digital [ __ ]
like you're dizzy like those like like a
like an electric like an electric clock
remember the digital clock first came
out 1980s unit like green little [ __ ]
blueish green never you have that
your album cover kind of like police
album like ghost in the machine album
cover yeah yeah but I think that's the
thing though it's like a band even in
1980 well I don't know cuz I was only
like eight years old a ninety but had I
heard of a band called Gemini I wouldn't
necessarily think like hey Jackson five
I would have thought like I don't know I
would have felt like a disco band he's
talking about I would have thought disco
he's talking about a black Duran Duran
with children with well 15 16 year olds
a boyband like menudo the ones he was
picking up were like 10 or 11 or 12
Oh 13 yeah but yes menudo
one of them was nine it's like that
that's how I think menudo okay no I
don't think so
well they well they menudo had different
care about me and they could still be
around because they once they got like
it was like Logan's Run like well yeah
that's a certain age they had a great
carousel it's like nobody would to care
so that's the conspiracy theory that
nobody wants you to know about okay
carousel I want to see the luggage run
again now yeah we still get hits on that
fit yeah we did it so long again big
hits on [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah
Logan's Run they love our Logan's Run
video yeah and I had it I had a good I
think I had a good idea of what the
ending was yeah that the egg cracked
open to let them all out yeah you know
to see my Logan's run analysis you need
to remake Logan's Run just like that but
modernize it a little bit I don't know I
don't know if I like that idea
well see what you will I mean I'm sure
they'll get around to it but I don't
know it's and I like the TVs the same
and I like the TV series need to watch a
TV series again I got it I got that [ __ ]
on blu-ray I don't know I got it on DVD
got the whole [ __ ] yeah I didn't like
it as much as the movie off topic off
topic people are going [ __ ] god
damnit why are you guys going off topic
I don't know I feel like most people
like it well the thing too is that this
video in particular we started talking
about the case like right away yeah so
by the time we got to this point yeah
you know we go off-topic
people are already invested yeah we're
probably like an hour into this [ __ ]
show anyway I think we might be why do
you want to take a break why almost got
I'm almost done with this drink
but the thing is I gotta finish it
because I don't have any more of that
damn red ball okay so I got it I gotta
clear it out you gotta clear I gotta
clear it out and then I'm gonna make
another one got a reset got a reset okay
well let me let me talk a couple more
minutes I'll finish out the I'll finish
out 1980 and then I'll let you do the
[ __ ] because your drinks looking good it
is yeah it's not like that shows flying
by well he well you made it really
strong so I'm drinking her okay he makes
the drinks I don't even watch what he's
doing he could be put in like all kind
of poison in there that one's like that
that one's like a triple yeah well it's
better now it's like now it's kind of
like watered down yeah when I first when
I first drank it I was like oh okay yes
nice but yeah so when they found
Christopher Richardson who like I said
was 12 he had different swim trunks on
than the last time he was seen so that's
a little weird um his body was found in
January of 1981 now his body was found
alongside another victim Earl Tyrell who
was actually disappeared later on which
we will get to now here was another now
this is another one that I don't think
it's usually like said in the same
series at the same time live but again I
think this is somebody else cuz this is
some different [ __ ] going on right here
June 22nd 1980 a seven-year-old girl
named Latonya Wilson disappeared from
her parents apartment now this [ __ ] I
think this happened in like broad
daylight so there's two guys one of them
is seen by a witness climbing into the
apartment window like digging up the
screen climate in the apart
and then taken the big little girl out
of the apartment like out of the window
and like carriage I don't know she was
sleeping if they drugged her or whatever
now I do think that when they went in
because the parents were sleeping in the
apartment so maybe it was a nighttime
the parents were sleeping in the
apartment I think she had at least one
sibling maybe two that were sleeping in
the same room and they didn't wake up
this dude like climbs in the window
picks up this little girl out of her bed
and takes her out the [ __ ] window
right so like apparently a witness saw
this and report it to police and I don't
think the police did anything or they
didn't believe her and then later on
like several months later they found her
body
damn and she was a skeleton and they
couldn't tell how she had died and they
didn't believe the witness that said hey
there was these two guys and one of them
climbed in the [ __ ] window and just
took her out the [ __ ] window
two guys did that yeah so I don't know
like I was she seven she didn't fight I
think she was sleeping didn't wake up I
guess not
I found words like a few cases that
happened like I've written about a
couple cases that happen like this where
people were somebody just came in the
window and like took a kid like while
they were sleeping
you wouldn't think it'd be possible I
guess it is I could see it because the
kids is out tomorrow my daddy taking
that's what I mean I mean the little kid
they might kind of wake up it's like oh
it's mom or something like that because
you know I've seen like people carrying
around little kids and they look like
[ __ ] knocked out you know what I mean
so it's possible that's some weird [ __ ]
but [ __ ] scary but I don't know if
this was the summer they described I
don't know if she got like a super good
look at him but she did say that like
one of them like brought the girl out
and then was like talking to another
dude and then they took off and then
they later found that girl like it was
they found she disappeared in June and
then they found her in October like but
she was already a skeleton so that kind
of that kind of lends credence to a
[ __ ] pedophile ring thing flossing
yeah I'm not ruling that out yeah
because there was a lot of weird [ __ ]
going on but I'm telling you that's
different than the Wayne way
that's a very different a different
[ __ ] I mean I don't think Wayne
Williams would have the balls know to
crawl in somebody's window he was more
I'm gonna lure people into my car kind
of dude yeah when Wayne Williams is what
this is what I'm thinking he's doing all
right this is based on everything I've
heard of this guy and you're refreshing
my memory telling this story he's but
but I think he's doing he's pretending
to be a talent scout yeah and he's using
the [ __ ] silver tongue to get these
boys to get in the car with him and then
he's telling his boys everything these
boys want to hear then he bless them
yeah and then kills him and kills him
yeah um no I don't know why he thinks he
can't let him go I don't you know what I
mean because they're guys that do that
let him go and come back and molest him
again yeah you know I mean for some
reason he thinks he has to kill him or
the part of the kill of the kill is also
part of the thrill I I suspect it's that
one maybe you know I mean maybe it
really does seem like weight or he's
just so scared to let one of them go
because they'll rat him out
or the or he gets rejected so then he
forces himself on him yeah well and he
might be killing them too because I mean
people did know him in that neighborhood
like he wasn't as famous as he claimed
to be but people did know who he was and
they did know that he was like trying to
recruit kids for his for this boy band
that he was putting together so maybe he
felt like he had to kill them because
it's like hey if somebody like
recognized you know what I mean if you
know he would know who I was yeah maybe
some of the kids knew him like from
around the neighborhood and stuff
he's like well I have to kill them
otherwise they'll like [ __ ] narc yeah
he doesn't maybe he's afraid of getting
he's afraid of getting a reputation of
being a pedophile yes he'll because you
see there's [ __ ] loads and loads of
cases of guys just seducing kids a book
of either sex and then just having
[ __ ] constant relationships with them
over a period of years at that age and
if some dudes that could do it yeah I
don't know why he decided to he had to
kill him
it can only mean that that kill them as
part of his motive yeah that he's
getting getting into that and like you
said I think he didn't want it getting
around yes into that or something like
that you're right because he because he
was kind of known like rebel didn't know
him around the neighborhood so I don't
think he wanted maybe he's thinking
maybe yeah maybe I figured it he risked
his reputation too much that's what yeah
he had to kill because you know he seems
to me very much somebody that you know
because of his inflated resume and his
inflated ego and everything he seems
somebody who is very much like a
reputation oriented person so you would
definitely want to maintain you know a
certain like facade yeah that's what it
is because I've seen stuff on just damn
serial pedophiles they got serial
pedophiles out there some of them are
less than twenty thirty kids and most of
those kids didn't rat that dude out or
even if I feel like sometimes too
depending on who the kid is and
depending on who the dude is um
sometimes they do ride them out but they
don't get they don't believe that
happens right and they don't do anything
right so that's another most of the time
the pedophile uses a lot of like [ __ ]
praise and [ __ ] he knows how to pick
them you know me picks them for picks
them because they have that they have
parents that the kid doesn't like the
parents so yeah they know how to scream
he's not a groom and the kids choosing
the pedophile over the parents because
you know the the pedophile is better to
the kids in the parent yeah maybe he's
nicer time giving them whatever they
wanted so he's basically bribing the kid
yeah oh I think that happens a lot that
that happens and I think a lot of people
don't understand that you see we grew up
in a different era where they would talk
about that [ __ ] on television you'd have
that [ __ ] on [ __ ] Geraldo and stuff
where they would talk about serial
pedophiles and some of these dudes were
[ __ ] playing 13 14 kids at one time
for years but you don't see that you
don't hear about that as much as you
used to well I think there's a lot more
awareness about it yeah right it's not
right because I mean when we were
growing up you know and even blick prior
to that like these kids were about my
age like in the you know
70s early 80s it's like yeah you kind of
heard about that [ __ ] but it wasn't like
I don't know I just I just feel like
there was a thing where if you're a
little enough kid and like you said
maybe your parents are not around or
maybe you don't like them for whatever
reason I mean you know these are little
kids and you meet some guy and he's kind
of like he seems kind of cool and he's
like telling you all this [ __ ] you want
to hear and he's giving you presents and
suppose that you want maybe some kids
would not think that was suspicious I
mean that's not that's not a ding on
kids at all it's like they're kids they
don't know yeah and some of them didn't
care - yeah that is well so I'm they
were letting them smoke they were
letting them drink right they were
letting to stay over at the [ __ ]
house they were letting them do stuff
like that so but what you're talking
about is I'm not talking a lot of times
about chill you know like little kids
we're talking about 13 14 15
that's usually what they were going for
rebellious teenagers that's a lot that
was the the most common ones that they
went for rebellious teenagers coming out
of homes that were getting breaking up
broken home type yeah do you well I'm
like your abusive homes people that are
you know pedophiles that target kids you
know regulate regularly they know how to
target children yeah talk to children
they know how to bribe them like you
said you know hey come to mind so he has
all the best video games he has like a
big TV he is always under kind of [ __ ]
and you know they they know how to like
play the kids weaknesses I guess like
because that's their whole thing yeah
and then there was like some of the
shit's kind of like weird morally gray
like I knew a girl um you don't know her
I don't think I've ever mentioned her to
you she was from New Orleans she ran
away from home at probably about
fourteen with a with a nut with a goth
guy who was probably about 23 yeah
alright but when you really heard her
family's story I kind of understand why
she ran away from the [ __ ] family oh
yeah
happens and the dude was loved her was
nice to her yeah you know totally
illegal but totally illegal but he did
protect her yeah and he protected her
from the family you know there was bad
[ __ ] going on at the family home so and
I don't think he he wasn't per se
grooming or anything was just to goth
kids yeah you know they were into the
same [ __ ] and there was an age
difference and she came from a [ __ ]
bad family and running off with this guy
which he was a good looking guy but
running off with that guy was a
beneficial to her
yeah the law is not gonna look at that
as if that was [ __ ] right well
because in most cases it's not right but
you know there are there may be cases
like that yeah
where'd that happen because like I said
if I was I knew the dude he was a good
dude yeah but I didn't know that that
had happened right cuz I met them after
she was already about 20 right yeah I
mean I didn't realize how long they had
been together yeah but it's just weird
you know that means just people you
[ __ ] run into you know what I mean
but you know she came from a very
abusive [ __ ] home but I can
understand I mean had I come from I mean
you know my family was very you know
nice normal yeah but if I had come from
a horrible family like that I mean when
I was 13 or 14 years old of some like
older dude to come along and said hey
run off with me to some other side of
this yeah and I totally would have done
it though I understand I understand that
yeah and you know I and I just man the
law would say that was [ __ ] bad
mm-hmm but I'm not gonna say all the
details but knowing all the details in a
way he rescued her yesyes we're over
yeah like that happens there's kind of
like you know obviously kids that are
like really really young and do that
really obviously that is [ __ ] up and
then not be allowed
however like in the middle there's this
window where it's kind of like it's kind
of I think it has to be taken on a
case-by-case yes you know what I mean
yeah because especially if there's not
like a huge age difference like I said
if it's like a teenager and like
somebody in their 20s
yeah that's we
but it's not you know you just have to
take it on a case-by-case basis now when
you're talking about like an
eight-year-old kid and yeah 40 year old
dairy they're obviously yeah that should
not be loud ever but when it's teenagers
and somebody that's just out of teens
yeah that's a little more and it's a
teenager running from a bad environment
yeah that to a much better they won't be
some extenuate into a much better
environment yeah so I definitely think
that should be taken on case-by-case but
yeah so I said I was gonna finish out
1980 before you finish drink okay so the
day after Latanya Wilson disappeared was
taken out of her [ __ ] parents
apartment by whoever um the next day
June 23rd Aaron why she was ten years
old
disappeared after running an errand to a
local grocery store that was near his
house he was seen getting into a blue
Chevrolet now the witness said they
there was either one or two men in the
car like two black men now another
witness said that she saw Aaron wife
being led from the grocery store by
someone who did not look like Wayne
Williams she said this was a six-foot
tall 180 pound black male now Wayne
Williams was only about five foot seven
and was kind of like was younger was
much younger cuz this dude that she said
she saw was about Suri
whereas Wayne Williams was only in his
early 20s um and didn't weigh 180 pounds
either he was like kind of ass when he
was a little bit pudgy when he was
younger but he wasn't
um you know he wasn't a big dude and
also she said that the guy that she saw
Aaron Bush with had a mustache and a
goatee now the description of the car
that she saw the blue Chevrolet was
similar to the description that had been
given in the case of the Jeffrey Mathis
abduction so like I said we're talking
about a couple of different cars here um
and I'm not saying that the witness
report was necessarily accurate I mean
cuz you know but there's not any reason
to think it wasn't accurate either so
maybe we're talking about like I said an
accomplice or maybe there was more than
one going on
so the next day after that they found
Aaron washes body under a bridge now the
official cause of death again
asphyxiation
now they said he had died from a broken
back so first they said well it's
possible that he could have fallen off
the bridge and died accidentally however
his family were like you know he was
terrified of heights he would not have
gone on that bridge he would have jumped
off the bridge he wouldn't have done in
that kind of [ __ ] so I kind of feel like
this is they do treat it like a homicide
and they're saying you know he could
have you know been strangled and then
fallen and broken his neck or whatever
but um you know they can't really say
since the neck was broken since they
didn't find any like evidence of you
know ligature or anything like that so
they can't definitively say it was
asphyxiation however they did say that
it was or they couldn't definitively say
it was strangulation now July of 1980
there were two more children Anthony
Carter and Earl Terrell who were also
murdered between August and November of
1985 more killings took place all the
victims african-american children
between the ages of 7 and 14 all of them
killed via asphyxiation or strangulation
you know asphyxiation could be
strangulation or it could be suffocation
or you know could be the thing so we're
already up to the word I mean 1981 and
we're already like - oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
enough [ __ ] crimes so you want to take
a break so you can refill yeah I'm gonna
refill my so we gotta take a break right
now and when we get back we will talk
some more about the Atlanta child
murders case
Hey Baby cookie what you doing oh you're
looking out the window what's going on
out there huh what's going on yeah
you look all contemplative no you don't
want to be on TV today okay I'm sorry
you look all chill look at your local
you're so cool
you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
hey you were back
all right talking about the Atlanta
child murders so when we last left we
were talking about nineteen eighty now
we're into nineteen eighty one in which
the murders obviously continue first
known victim of 1981 was Looby Jeter now
he disappeared on January 3rd his body
was found about a month later on
February 5th now he had a friend and
named Terry Pugh that also went missing
in January the weird thing about the
Terry Pugh case was that before they
found his body um the police received an
anonymous call saying where his body was
now I've heard from a couple different
documentaries and sources and stuff like
that that the caller sounded like a
white person um I'm not sure if that's
the case or not
but when they went and checked out where
the body but they did find the body
there so this is clearly somebody that
knew where the body was now
interestingly Terry Pugh lived in the
same apartment building as Edward Smith
who had been killed back in 1979 he was
one of the first victims as a matter of
fact so between February and March of
1981 there were six more bodies
discovered and these were all believed
to be linked to the previous murders now
among these was Eddie Duncan which was
believed to be the first adult victim
now as I said previous to this all of
the victims had been essentially
children or very young teenagers
preteens whatever but at some point the
murderer did seem to start targeting
older individuals now if you guys saw
the second season of mind hunter where
they kind of went into this a little bit
this has been fictionalized somewhat for
the show and everything but the
profilers did get brought in and they
did predict that at some point because
the killer was probably an
attention-seeking type of killer that
they would be following media coverage
of the crimes and that they might
possibly change their MO or their victim
profile slightly or the way they dumped
their bodies or whatever
like after the the crimes had gotten to
like a particular case so they you know
so so he would like think that it was
like a different killer he was trying to
make it look like a different killer you
know I'm saying yeah so they're saying
this is somebody that's following the
police investigation know something
about police investigation and so
therefore might change [ __ ] up a little
bit and indeed that is exactly what
happened because if Wayne Williams said
indeed commit all these crimes he did
start targeting slightly older victims
and he also started dumping them in
rivers instead of in the woods which the
FBI profilers also predicted that he
would do particularly after news of
fiber evidence started going public now
they didn't want to because they had
actually found some fibers on some of
the victims and you have to think this
is like the early like late 70s early
nineteen eighties fiber evidence was
kind of still not seen as like that
biggest thing so when the investigators
were like hey we have like the same like
carpet fibers that we found like on this
body on that body a lot of the police
didn't really want to they didn't really
take it all that seriously you know what
I mean like they kind of thought it was
like you know whatever like it wasn't
like a big deal it's like oh yeah it's
like a same carpet big [ __ ]
whoop-dee-doo
but there is actually like a real
legitimate science behind that and I
don't think the police like understood
that in the late seventies early
eighties so the fact that they had like
the same carpet fibers on several of the
victims was kind of a big deal and I
think they didn't like really see it
well they probably didn't think a jury
would buy it that's the only thing they
care about you know will the jury
[ __ ] conviction evidence like that if
I didn't think it would work ironically
I think that was one of the things that
made the jury convicted yet was all the
fiber they bought it because they didn't
have any other they had some witness
statements they had the name any
fingerprints and everything but
obviously there's no DNA back then but
the fiber evidence I think did go a long
way toward convicting Wayne Williams and
also him taking the stand in his own
defense was probably a mistake Williams
going for older older guys
actually is a sign that maybe what it
was is that was more what he was into
yeah he went after the little ones first
some practice yeah well he didn't have
his confidence yeah he knew he could
take those yeah but that might have been
exactly but but then once once he got
good at daddy's like you know I could
handle him it they're a little bit older
too so yeah no I'm challenging and
throught he's probably more into the
older ones I bet yup more you know older
teens probably right
so he was punching down at first yeah
you know that and that that's what he
was doing and because he wasn't sure if
he wasn't sure if he could do want it
you know a little older but then he's
like yeah I could get the older ones I
mean he's not a bit he's not an
intimidating dude would you see the dude
he's that very feminine well he's kind
of dumpy he was kind of dumpy if it lost
a lot of weight in prison I noticed yes
I saw him in 2010 and he seemed very
thin he's very [ __ ] you know he's not
he's not a macho guy or it doesn't exude
[ __ ] much his MO in any way so he
didn't want to buy it off more and he
could chew and but then when you know he
got some practices and he's like you
know I can go for the older ones too so
you know once he his confidence got
built up although and he was like that
he's like you know what imma [ __ ] dump
them in a river you know he was he's
trying to disappear off the radar he's
was trying to do well like I said after
the fiber evidence became public he
would have known enough about law
enforcement techniques because he did
actually read about that kind of [ __ ] he
was kind of a cop groupie like I said he
would have known that maybe that could
finger him so and as I said that's why
the FBI profiler said he's gonna start
dumping bodies in the river to get rid
of the evidence
and that's exactly what he did right
exactly yeah he's trying to disappear
yeah so you know um also and I think I
mentioned this earlier but a lot but I
think I believe all of the adults that
he killed were childlike in some way
they were either small in billed he
likes you over short or they were like
you know
mentally impaired in some way he was
looking for twinks yeah I guess
basically although like I said sure they
were you know yeah
earth in or something um like you said
he wasn't a real big dude he looks thin
now because he's been in prison for a
long time like I said I saw an interview
with him that was from I believe it's
from 2010 which is you know a long time
ago now but I don't know what he looks
like now but he he was much thinner in
2010 but when they caught him he wasn't
fat but he was just like dumpy looking
you know he was just like a dumpy
looking 5 foot 7 he had big old glasses
a big ol afro you know Twinkie
[ __ ] something like yeah yeah
Susie Q's I said this might be another
diversion but it's like remember like
the [ __ ] was it Dolly Madison that
made those [ __ ] yeah Susie Q is he
[ __ ] the hostess I like this like an
orange hostess cupcakes remember the
orange hostess cupcakes are orange
frosting first wasn't with frost is like
fondant you could pull it off the top of
it yeah well it's not like this [ __ ]
chocolate ones they look like those
swirly things yeah and then you had the
Ding Dongs and they came and they
changed it to King dogs yeah what the
hell was that
dan you want you just say it ding-dong I
thought that was two different innings I
thought it was Ding Dongs and then King
dongs was the kind of ripoff no it was
you know it's big rocks and that it was
an Oreo night rocks came first in came I
believe I believe based on my [ __ ]
memory is it based on your lace don't
know no based on my memory it was ding
dongs and they and overtime it caught a
lot of flak for that say change it to
King Dawn's see I remember both of those
things but I think there are two
separate brands oh now I have to weaken
I remember that same damn character the
drawing of the [ __ ] with the other
get a scepter in the crown
yeah and then later on the [ __ ] I
actually liked the orange cupcakes
they're better best I remember the
[ __ ] hostess cupcakes they were
orange it's orange frosting and they had
to
can whites curlicue going down the top
of it yeah with the frosting how could I
mean how could you how could you choose
a Twinkie over that and I like Twinkies
but given a choice between a Twinkie and
the orange hostess cupcake I'm going to
take that orange hose
oh is this cookie I'm gonna take that
orange cupcake anytime in [ __ ] time
and you know what you take that [ __ ]
and you put it in a microwave well yeah
15 seconds yeah just a totally different
it's a totally different experience yeah
yeah Little Debbie O'Neill few seconds
[ __ ] change it into a totally
different I was gonna say that you know
as far as dolly Mason classy after he
had been oh yeah that was like white
trash but yeah yeah but you have that
with your [ __ ] RC Cola but I would be
nuts in it yeah with what I was gonna
say about Dolly Madison was that for
some reason the thing that I liked the
most was they had murmur they had those
pies yeah yeah they were big
yeah yeah they had fruit ones like the
fruits are good too but for some reason
for like a year or two I like you I like
the chocolate
I knew you was like the pudding inside
and had like Snoopy on the front yeah I
don't know why I wait I went through
like a phase where I was happily one
they were all Jerry once the lemons good
they're all good if you guys there were
pretty much all filling yeah if you've
never huge they were like a [ __ ]
calzone
if you're in Europe and you don't know
what you don't know what we're talking
about you don't know what you're missing
you didn't know what you're missing
these are white trash desserts in the
South the South was created on the back
of those [ __ ] desert and they just
came out of damn dime stores they just
came out of dime stores they were
responsible for all the did all of the
diabetes all the [ __ ] Diamond did
diabeetus [ __ ] right man those things
were good all that Little Debbie [ __ ]
the big old [ __ ] Nutter butters
yeah hell yeah I'm not a burglar they
call it the bird they call it nutty
wafer David it's like I said I checked
the thing I'd honestly like my favorite
it probably my favorite Little Debbie
like back in the day was the zebra cakes
those are good too
we got to get back to the show these
people are [ __ ] getting fat just
listen but yes all about those things
you get a huge [ __ ] case of that [ __ ]
for five bucks you get a pallet for $20
well they like the whole box used to be
$0.99 99 cents for a huge [ __ ] box
they're not anymore but they used to be
yeah
southerners know all about mass anime
[ __ ] we like to watch it if there's more
room so based on volume by mass yeah
massive volume that's why you drink out
of like big huge charge how big is it
that's all we care about how big is this
it's like we don't care if it tastes
good or not which I want a lot of it
cheap you get a lot yeah yeah so at this
stage it seems like you started killing
adult victims the first of which was
Eddie Duncan now in April of 1981 they
also found another adult 20 year old
Larry Rogers then there was one named
John Porter who was 28 and 21 year old
Jimmy ray Payne they were also murdered
now John Porter and Jimmy ray Payne were
actually ex-convicts they had just been
released from the state prison they had
been in there for burglary
now may 12th 1981 FBI agents who had
been brought in on one particular case
of an abduction of one of the victims
because they thought that the victim had
been taken over state lines because they
got an anonymous call from somebody that
said they were in Alabama and that they
had taken the kid I don't know I don't
think that lead panned out because they
found the body later and it wasn't in
Alabama but the fact that they had got
that phone call like justified them
bringing the FBI in on the case because
that was like taking an abduction victim
over the thing so that so the FBI were
involved like from from fairly or one in
the case so May 12th 1981 the FBI agents
found another older victim a 17 year old
William Barrett now he was found in a
wooded area near his home now
a witness who was who worked at high
school and he had like running a gas or
something and he saw a black man
standing over the bridge like from where
you know the body was found like
underneath and he saw that man standing
and he later said that that at the trial
that that looked like Wayne Williams
like standing there looking over the
bridge to where the where the body was
later found
he said the guy drove away in a
two-toned Cadillac which was white on
the top and blue on the bottom which I
don't think that Williams had a car like
that most of most of the people that saw
his car said it was like a white station
wagon but like I said he had a couple of
cars that he was running and like I said
there might have been [ __ ]
accomplices too so end of May 1981 was
the last victim of this particular
series now this was a 27 year old named
Nathaniel cater now this guy was
apparently seen by a garden herb named
Robert Henry he saw him at the light
coming out of the Rialto Theatre in
downtown Atlanta and he said that he was
holding hands with Wayne Williams now
it's weird because I saw like in the CNN
documentary which came out in 2010 they
interviewed him and they said well
that's what you said at the original
trial that you said the guy that he was
holding hands with was Wayne Williams
but then in later term like later you
said that it wasn't him but he said that
when he said that it wasn't Wayne
Williams that he had been like asked to
say that you know what I mean like his
like Wayne Williams was trying to get
another trial so he was trying to like
drum up whatever and like I don't know
if somebody gave him some money to say
hey say it wasn't Wayne or whatever I
don't know but he said on the
documentary he's like yeah they told me
like to say it was someone else but I'm
telling you right now in 2010 that it
was Wayne Williams and I'm completely
certain of that because I knew that guy
hmm so he said he saw them both like
they were holding hands and they were
coming out and that was like the last
time that Nathaniel Kater was seen alive
you know I mean yes so suspicious now at
this stage like I said there there's
some controversy over which murders like
fall into this particular series because
there are between 28 and 30 like
canonical ones and what's called the
Atlanta child murders case however I
have read that there were some other
case
perhaps as many as 60 that were left out
for whatever reason either because they
thought the victim was too old or
because of the location or because of
the way the victim was killed or
whatever even though it's very strange
that some of the murders that were
allegedly left out were kind of similar
to ones that were left in so I don't
know and like I said there was one
particular murder that I was thinking of
of a girl where the girl was found tied
to a tree with her hands behind her back
and she'd been sexually assaulted stuff
like that just like that just like that
twelve-year-old girl early on and I feel
like that was similar enough that that
was probably the same killer although I
don't think it was Wayne Williams I
think so I think there was another
killer it was doing that at least one
other serial killer like operating
around the same time whether they knew
each other or were operating together I
don't really know but unlikely yeah I
think that there was more than one but I
do think that Wayne Williams was I don't
think he was wrongfully convicted or
anything like that densely populated
area statistic in it back in those
dairies there probably would be more
than one yeah which is already but it
does happen it's unusual but it does
happen I mean like I said we've done a
show we've done a lot of shows about
that where there's just like a
particular geographic yeah anomaly where
for some reason we've done shows or
we've pointed out and some of this stuff
was [ __ ] that happened up north like in
Canada where a whole area of two or
three cities would be rapidly collapsing
because industry went away and for some
reason the damn serial killers come out
of that area and feed on it like maggots
[ __ ] feeding on a dime either that or
when a highway system would open up like
opening up new like avenues that hadn't
been opened before which I think was the
case in London Ontario where new
highways had just been built over the
area like new cities were building up so
sure killer crime yeah so it was almost
like new hunting grounds right and it
does seem like you know in the case of
London Ontario particularly it seems
like at least five serial killers if not
more we're going through that area at
around like in the same two decade time
period yeah and you can always kind of
pile on [ __ ] economic depressions
that as well you throw that on there
where you have collapsing economies
crime
is up including serial murder and serial
rape yes it's because prostitution goes
up because poverty's gone up all kinds
of weird [ __ ] happen well yeah there's
like an algorithm well there's a lot of
circumstances that come about from
economic deprivation you know and um so
at this stage you can imagine so in
Atlanta because it had taken so long and
you know it did take forever for the
police to actually come out in public
and acknowledge that a lot of these
crimes were probably committed by the
same person even though very early on
when this [ __ ] started happening
obviously a lot of the parents of the
you know victims and stuff were
constantly you know contacting the
police being like hey would you guys
like link all these murders clearly they
were committed by the same person but
the police didn't really want to say
that and it really did seem like even
though the city of Atlanta at the time
they had a black mayor and like
Commission or everything like that but
it's like they didn't want to say that
there was a serial killer because
Atlanta I mean a lot of their revenue
comes from like conferences and like a
lot of you know it's it's like a huge
travel hub in the United States and I
guess they didn't want to like scare
people from off from visiting there or
from coming there like for business
purposes also they were initially afraid
that the killer might be white which
might spark off kind of race riots
they'd be afraid that if this was a
white killer or if it was some from the
KKK which they did suspect for a time
and like I said they did put several KKK
members including a guy named George
Sanders and his family members they put
them under surveillance for a very long
time because they thought they might
have something to do with it because
they made some kind of sketchy
statements about the crimes so so the
FBI did investigate that so there was
some feeling that one the crimes are not
being investigated as a serial killer
even though a lot of the families knew
very early on that it probably was a
serial killer and two you know that
there was some fear in the community
that there might be some kind of
cover-up yeah now hold on one second let
me explain something
the reason why they thought the Klan
might have been involved in this that
was a theory it's not they're not saying
that the Klan was are a bunch of
pedophiles that's not what what the
theory was there was a theory that the
Klan was going out and killing black
children to try to create a black
uprising against the police yeah in
which the police and white people would
wipe out black people in this big that's
essentially and one so the a police
informant did who had been KKK did
actually tell the police that she's been
talking about this thought that that's
what it was yeah but nah that's not it
was that's not yeah I mean like I said
when they did some investigation you
soon as some of the remembers they had
under surveillance didn't say some
really sketchy [ __ ] Evers like the phone
and stuff but they didn't find any
evidence that they were like you know in
involved in these particular crimes yeah
although like I said they did have an
informant that told them that the KKK
had actually talked about doing this
particular thing killing one black child
a month which is kind of what happened I
mean some of them were closer together
than that but there was a period where
pretty much one every month or whatever
couple problem with this theory is that
the Klan during this period and this
also applies to today it's a bunch of
[ __ ] talkers they [ __ ] talk [ __ ] I've
known Klan members but I've known other
[ __ ] you know guys that were like you
know [ __ ] well you call ho temps and
[ __ ] black Israelites you know I've
hung out with [ __ ] a lot of crazy
[ __ ] and they all [ __ ] say
crazy [ __ ] they don't tend to do nearly
what they [ __ ] say because they're
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] nuts you know I
mean if they come up with these [ __ ]
crazy ideas and they they talk [ __ ] but
most of it is about impressing trying to
impress somebody they talk [ __ ] yeah but
they don't deliver most of them talk to
talk they don't walk to walk doesn't
matter what same thing with neo-nazi
self [ __ ] talk
kinds of [ __ ] but they don't ever do a
[ __ ] if fat dudes at the bar
that's all day that's what they do they
get the party [ __ ] drink talk [ __ ]
yeah I mean there is a small percentage
that do you what they're saying but mo
yes Hawkins talking [ __ ]
yeah but yes so you know so there was a
lot of tension you know with the [ __ ]
like you know all of the families were
crying and the mother of one of the
victims Camille Belle she actually
decided before the police really got
serious about investigating these is a
series of serial case serial killer
cases she kind of got a lot of the other
mothers and they kind of like put
together a committee and they were kind
of like well we're gonna like you know
catch this dude ourselves they even put
together like vigilante groups who would
go like bats and [ __ ] like that like
looking for the person and it's this is
really [ __ ] sad but one of the kids
that was killed
Patrick Hofstetter Hostetter I believe
his name was I can't remember his last
name was Balthazar Balthazar Patrick
ball bounces are I believe he was 11 or
12 years old the sad thing about this is
that he was one of those kids that he
wanted to I mean because at one point
they put forward a huge reward the city
put put up $100,000 and then I believe
Muhammad Ali contributed another 400
thousands it was like half a million
dollar reward so this little kid Patrick
Balthasar said I'm gonna go out and
catch the serial killer who's 12 years
old and cuz he's like cuz I'm gonna get
the money in a move by my mama house and
also he wanted the reward money so he
thought I could and he got murdered
damn horrible it's like I was watching
this [ __ ] [ __ ] on the [ __ ] on the
documentary and it's just like hearing
that about yeah and here find out who
did it no well he was one of the he was
one of the second Annika yeah he was one
of the canonical and so they think that
went way no one knew about him maybe
damn I mean the [ __ ] like this like you
watch the documentaries with some of the
mothers and stuff like that and like
this one case I think it was it might
have been the Camila Cabello case or it
might have been
the Patrick Baltazar case where you know
the victim had like a three-year-old
sister and the three-year-old sister was
terrified like after her her big brother
that was her big brother and he got
murdered and she was like terrified to
leave the house she was only three and
it's like she thought if her like big
strong brother could leave the house and
never come back and get murdered then
then it can happen to her and another
thing that happened to was that every
time the mom said like every time there
was fog outside she would go outside and
start looking for her brother because
she thought that the fog was heaven
coming down her brother would be in it
yeah terrible this is you know this is
random you have reminded me of the
original Night Stalker yeah remember
hide they'd have those big fan that had
those big neighborhood [ __ ] meetings
they were all televised and one dude
stood up I don't understand how these
men can't defend their women yeah I'm
ready for the [ __ ] Night Stalker if
he comes to get me and then [ __ ] dude
heard him and [ __ ] target in his ass
and occasionally didn't he kill him or
he'd know he just raped his wife didn't
he yeah he made him watch or you know
sit outside yeah it sounds like when
Williams heard about the kid and maybe
maybe saw him as a threat and said well
I'll seduce him and kill him I'm not
sure yeah I'm not sure if like all this
stuff about it and that might have come
out after he was murdered I'm not really
sure but I think that it might have come
out beforehand so maybe he did hear
about it because he definitely seemed
like somebody like you said like the
original night The Night Stalker just
Angelo but you [ __ ] spoke up and
[ __ ] took D'Angelo's name in vain you
would [ __ ] pay dude was a cop he had
cop skills well if you come after you in
[ __ ] getting your grad [ __ ] window
and set up an ambush inside your own
goddamn house and rape your wife yeah
that's what I mean like make you wait
outside why he was raping your wife
that's the [ __ ] humiliation there
it's very easy to talk big when nothing
of yours is on the line yeah but I will
say that it's like there's always a
bigger fish there even maybe not even
bigger fish
but maybe they have a gun and you don't
or maybe they have a Merton you know
they are they getting your house and you
don't know that they're in there it's
like somebody can always [ __ ] with you
diangelo have you had the ability to
guide to ID you and find what find out
where you lived and would break into
your house when you were at work
and they'd wait [ __ ] yeah and set up
the [ __ ] house and unload all your
guns find you anywhere you'd hide your
guns you gonna hide your guns near your
bed yeah I mean so he'd unload all that
[ __ ] and [ __ ] disable your [ __ ]
window latches your window locks and
then leave and wait for you to come home
and go to sleep and he'd come through
that window that he unlocked and [ __ ]
bust in through your [ __ ] bedroom
window
[ __ ] put a spotlight on you he had a
gun and a mask and [ __ ] down what do
you to rest your ass basically that's a
big banner yeah it's like put handcuffs
on you put you out [ __ ] front outside
your [ __ ] bedroom door put a bunch of
[ __ ] dishes over your head he says if
I hear these [ __ ] dishes luckily hit
the ground or clatter I'm gonna shoot
your wife and then he [ __ ] take your
wife and [ __ ] jump in your bed and
rape your wife and your bed you had to
sit out there listen to it yeah yeah
that's what I mean it's like I'm you
know and I'm not blaming anyone trying
yeah but he's trying to [ __ ] prove
his manhood over yours and here's the
deal the reason why I did it's cuz he's
a little dick [ __ ] couldn't
handle it yeah but well that's the thing
it's like just cuz you got a little dick
I mean Jeannie is my witness I don't
have that problem if you got that um
there's other record there's yeah yeah
for the record okay but I'm saying if
that's your prize if you got that
problem there's other ways there's other
ways to compensate you know I'm talking
about but you don't go out and [ __ ]
kill dudes and [ __ ] rape other
people's wives and [ __ ] just because you
were [ __ ] born like a [ __ ] without
saying but you know but evidently we do
have to say it but I'm telling you again
in D'Angelo's case that's what it boiled
down to it always does I think that's
what it was a big thing I think it was a
dick thing all of it all of them had a
grossest that all the killers are very
that's the thing about like studying
these
it in a way like I find them interesting
but in a way they're not none of them
are as smart as they think they are they
think they're like fooling a lot of
people with all this like sophistication
about like all their motives and stuff
like that I'm like it's all about your
dick
yeah boiled down pretty much is all it
boiled down to little dick OSIS yeah
yeah it always it always boils down to
to something dumb something it's not
little dick but it's it's always about
inadequate inadequacy yes always yeah
that is always what it is overcoming and
inadequacy yeah and a lot of times the
inadequacies being reinforced by the way
you focusing on it too much yeah because
every look everybody has inadequacy
everybody everyone does everybody but
it's how you deal with them that's and
people that become serial killers can't
deal with them in a healthy way
clearly but that's always what it boils
down to they feel inadequate in some way
yeah you just don't know what the [ __ ]
going on I mean one of the most popular
[ __ ] I can think of and my
generation would have been Prince for
all you know Prince might have been a
little [ __ ] you know no you
don't know probably not but he was a
short guy you know man but very popular
with the ladies and you know you just
don't know there's a bunch of different
ways you can [ __ ] play something but
in the case of D'Angelo I think little
dick OSIS got ahold of it yeah if you
get obsessed and other people had to pay
for it oh if you get obsessed with a
inadequacy whether perceived or real and
that's all you think about and all you
think about is going to work I've been
saving for that that is going to end in
tragedy you or someone else it's like
that's the thing what basically what you
have to do like I said everybody has
inadequacies weaknesses everybody has
that but everybody has strengths also
and what you need to do is just focus on
that hone that work that don't worry so
much about yeah you can work on
inadequacies you know you can do that
kind of [ __ ] like trying to make the
[ __ ] better but if it's stuff that you
can't do that much about then you have
to like not focus on it because that's
not gonna work out well for most of it
is things that you can control most of
it
I mean you know and even if it's not you
just have to like say you know [ __ ] it I
can't do anything about that and just
like try to do other [ __ ]
yeah I mean you know [ __ ] I mean let's
say you're a big fat [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's it and that's what you are yeah I
mean you may not be real popular with
skinny girls but you might end up being
[ __ ] mr. [ __ ] you know I mean mr.
what's-his-name you know I'm talking
about Jan you know I'm getting kind of
drunk out of that drunk the guy the guy
all the romance books are about [ __ ]
there my dear my Fabien no not you might
be a [ __ ] very you you might be very
popular with other with casa de casa no
that's cool you might not be very
popular with skinny girls but you might
be Casanova with overweight women
there's always a way there's always a
way there's yes is not saying too in a
way if you're a dude you have it easier
because women are a lot more forgiving
of physical differences if you have like
other [ __ ] to offer and we talked about
this before I'm like you can be like 400
pounds but if you are funny or you're
like really sore or something like that
you have something else to offer then I
don't think a lot of women would care
about that and if they did they kind of
suck so yeah you know I mean but yeah so
as we were saying I I feel like Wayne
Williams in this case again inadequacy
and I think it had something to do with
the fact that you know when he was a kid
when he was 16 years old there was kind
of like a big thing about how he had his
own Brady of station he ran a radio
station out of the basement of his
parents house when he was 16 which is
kind of impressive
he was even he was inject magazine he
was in like all this other kind yeah
that may not smell like much tuned after
you so I don't mean to interrupt you
guys want to expound on that okay
having your all back in the back in the
80s having your own [ __ ] radio station
as 16 coming out of your house that was
ultra [ __ ] cool you had a pirate
basically a pirate radio station yeah
even though I think he was actually
licensed wasn't he he might have been
yeah and well that's the thing like his
parents actually went into bankruptcy
paying for him to have a radio station
yeah and if you could run that right you
could make good money so I feel like
when he was a teenager he had like all
these big dreams I have a radius I'm
only 16 and I already have a radio
station he was getting some recognition
for it so he's like well I'm clearly
gonna be this big famous person who's
gonna discover the next big thing would
it be a millionaire but it'd be this any
other then a few years down the line
he's still living in his parents house
you know he's kind of still living in
Atlanta he's like kind of hustling
around trying to like recruit little
kids to [ __ ] band and he's like just
in this kind of two-bit operation and I
think he felt inadequate and I think
that he lashed out because well he kind
of made some mistakes instead of getting
already formed bands and playing their
[ __ ] and merchandising through through
that he probably had done a lot better
he could have been chicago's version of
[ __ ] k-rock kara okay was Atlanta
Atlanta yeah it could have been like
[ __ ] Atlanta's version of k-rock I
mean there's a lot you could go the
underground underground way yeah he
should have played he should have been
doing flaking like prototype rap and and
you know that would have worked but like
I said you know but hi sighs 2020 yeah
yeah that's what I'm saying it's like
and I'm not saying like you know I feel
like he had a lot of potential when he
was younger and the fact that he didn't
meet that potential even though he was
still very young I mean he was only 20
could have contributed to this I do feel
like inadequacy about that you got a
contributing you got a dude who's kind
of trying to distance himself from the
hood who's intelligent he's gay which is
already kind of a problem [ __ ] you
know I mean gay people are not really
[ __ ] that were that respected in a
and this is the early and it's the early
80s before gay acceptance okay say he's
trying to distance himself from all that
and become something special he's
intelligent he's got his own radio
[ __ ] station but it bombed out and
that might have been a big blow to his
ego yeah I think it was had that radio
station worked and he had [ __ ] been
doing something kind of underground that
was making a bunch of money and he was
making a name for himself there was a
possibility these murders never would
happened
yeah because I think his ultimate goal
he wanted to be famous
yeah which a lot of serial killers want
they want attention they want I'm not
saying that these dudes are born bad I
think it's a culmination of a lot of
things I think it is the heart of it is
all so [ __ ] bad luck there's a
possibility had he found success with
that radio station at 16 17 18 he would
have had a little bit more
self-acceptance maybe he would have
found a boyfriend you know dormant yeah
maybe a man if flakes started to have a
normal life right and maybe and it would
have gone and then this [ __ ]
would have been like a [ __ ]
eventually like a superstar yeah yeah or
a maker of stars yeah that coulda had a
producer yes he wanted to happen and the
fact that it didn't happen he couldn't
in truck which is a sign of [ __ ]
strong will and ego and [ __ ] you got
a very strong wheel and [ __ ] big ego
but [ __ ] doesn't go your way you throw a
[ __ ] temper tantrum yeah I think yeah
and then you know and then he becomes
perverted yes sexuality becomes
perverted yeah he just couldn't take it
anymore just like [ __ ] lashed out
when you think about it a tragedy on all
sides yeah almost kind of like and it
wasn't really I mean other than him
obviously it's his fault because he a
decision but I mean it wasn't anyone
else's fault
like nobody you know and it wasn't the
kind of thing where it's like oh he got
rejected by one person for like a music
producer job and then you know what led
to it so you know I just think it was a
conflation of factors he just didn't get
to where he thought he was going to get
to
he said it handled I'm still gonna blame
the [ __ ] because he decided to
do he was well yeah that's what I said
he could have just doubled down and put
his nose to the grindstone jinyoung
right he still he had on his 20s he
hasn't failed he hadn't filming [ __ ]
I always have a kid that age most dudes
that make it fail for a long [ __ ]
time yeah where they make it yeah it's
just that that [ __ ] got impatient yeah
and he had weirdness to him that he
allowed to take over and yeah a lot of
people didn't it's real weird and and
I'm and you know I'm sure he [ __ ]
regrets it because he probably realizes
it himself man I shouldn't done it it's
probably what it was although he's
probably like I shouldn't done that [ __ ]
I don't think I you know from what he's
an older guy now from what I've seen of
his interviews like I said the most
recent one I thought was 10 years ago
he's denying it right yeah he still
seems very evasive yeah well he's got a
deny he still seems like he thinks he's
smarter than everyone yeah um you know
Soledad O'Brien was she was asking him
some pretty point-blank questions and
like he would try to evade the question
and she would get on his ass about it
he's got a deny it he's in prison yeah
he can't [ __ ] admit in public and have
all his [ __ ] cell mates and [ __ ]
[ __ ] see him up there going yeah I
killed those little boys yeah that's not
good you're asking could you ask him to
[ __ ] up he can't admit they got no
patience for that kind of [ __ ]
but yeah so at this stage like I said
the FBI got involved they had done a
profile now as they showed on mine
hunter the profile that they put forward
before they even caught Wayne Williams
before Wayne Williams was even on
anyone's radar was you really accurate
to him they basically said that it was
gonna be like a young guy that was like
seeking attention
it was very ego driven they said it's
gonna be somebody that has kind of a job
but not like a great job somebody from
around that neighborhood but maybe
thinks they're a little bit better you
know and it you know the [ __ ] that they
said was gonna happen was like pretty
spot-on also they said it was somebody
that had either been a cop or was like a
cop groupie or like you know studied a
lot about cops and was interested in law
enforcement which was also true so they
kind of like call
a lot of the [ __ ] so because the FBI had
said that after the fiber evidence came
out that they were starting to link
these crimes because they'd found some
of the same carpet fibers in the same
blanket fibers of some dog hairs stuff
like that on you know a number of the
bodies that linked them all together so
the FBI profiler said well at this point
we think that the that the killer will
start dumping bodies into rivers so that
and may be nude so that there will be
less evidence to connect the crimes to
him and indeed that is exactly what
happened so what the FBI said they
should do was like well you guys should
put stakeouts on like all these bridges
like over the Chattahoochee River and
the South River like you know where some
of the other where some of the bodies
have been found and it's like we predict
that he will dump another body in this
river that will be where the next body
will be so they had 14 different sites
of stakeouts now they have the stakeout
going for I believe four weeks it was
like a month now they had been doing
this we 14 [ __ ] stakeout locations on
these bridges at different sites along
these two rivers where they had found
bodies in the past now for 28 days
nothing had happened and they were
starting to get a little annoyed so it
was very famously the last night that
they were gonna do a stakeout the last
night and one of the cops on one of the
bridges so some may 22nd 1981 here's a
fateful splash into the river and the
cop that cop heard a splash and then
another cop saw a white 1970 Chevrolet
station wagon turn around and drive back
across the bridge so they go and they
pull this dude over and guess who was in
the car 23-year old Wayne Bertrand
Williams now they asked him what he was
doing cuz it's kind of the middle of the
night you know they asked him what he
was doing
this was his parents car he said that he
had an appointment with a woman who was
gonna be like singing for him who's
gonna audition her
something like that I think he said her
name was Cheryl Johnson and he said she
just called me she gave me this phone
number she gave me this address I'm
supposed to meet her at her apartment at
7 a.m. and I didn't know where it was so
I was driving around looking for it
that's what he said now at this point I
think it's like a midnight or something
like the night before so they thought it
was a little fishy and also they saw in
his car there was like a - like a like
about a two-foot length of nylon rope
like in the car now they didn't
confiscate it at the time they didn't
have enough evidence to to arrest him at
this time I mean he's fished on a bridge
nobody saw him like throw anything off
the bridge nobody saw they just saw the
car they heard the splash and then they
saw the car like at the same time so
they figured the two things were related
and so they pulled him over but when
they checked out his story later about
this Cheryl Johnson person they could
not find any such person the phone
number that he gave them was bogus
it was either not connected or it was
like somebody that didn't know the [ __ ]
that was there was no such address the
address now he claimed later on oh well
this woman was probably just trolling
maybe you know they he didn't use those
words but that's essentially what he
said and he's like I didn't know I was
just like trying to find and another
thing too is that he said on this
particular day when they heard the
splash and he saw the car and everything
he said that he had been like playing
basketball at this one like place and
then he said oh I went to this one
studio to pick up something or whatever
now the the person like running the
basketball thing was like yeah he wasn't
here that day and also the person at the
studio where he supposedly came and
picked the [ __ ] up was like yeah he was
here picking [ __ ] up but it was the
night after that
so the alibi that he had for that night
was bogus I mean he lied to the police
essentially so they thought that was a
little suspicious so as now as I said
they didn't have now Nathaniel cater had
been reported missing at this point but
they had not found his body yet however
two days later after they had pulled
Wayne Williams over on this bridge they
found
his naked body in the river only a
couple miles from the bridge where they
had heard this plan just as he was
dumping it that's well yeah well
obviously I mean that seems like the
most likely sitting I'm telling you I'm
telling you if you're skeptical over the
over Wayne Williams as being the killer
Jenny and I have been doing this show a
long time we've been around the [ __ ]
block with this [ __ ] that's him
that was the dude they got it that's him
yeah like I said it was a couple of him
in there that I think it might have been
somebody else but I think he did most of
the canonical murders I think he was the
one that did those yeah and he well
everything matched up he matched it's in
every [ __ ] way there's a science to
this yeah
and that's him yeah I think so Tim hell
yeah they caught him in a [ __ ] stopped
yeah the canonical versions of the the
canonical murders stopped because he was
the one yeah
serial killer can't stop what they're
doing anymore and you can't stop jerking
off okay just because they catch Wayne
doesn't mean you're gonna stop if you're
the one that's doing it
bodies would have kept accruing yeah
then he kept showing up because the real
killer can't stop I mean because he was
captured and they stopped that meant
that that was him
I mean you know I'm not saying that
child murder stops completely know Sigma
John's with that signature they are they
were all from that area that's where
those boys were taken from now the weird
okay fits it he does he fits it [ __ ]
to a tee well like I said everything the
profilers came up with even though the
police of this because you have to think
this is like the early 80s we're
profiling wasn't really like a thing I
mean the whole FBI profiling department
hadn't even come into being until the
70s so this was fairly new and a lot of
like local police departments were still
like looking askance
and it's like what the [ __ ] could you
possibly know about anything you're not
even from here it's like you don't know
the people you don't know this is not
any other they didn't really get I think
they thought of it as like a bunch of
eggheads like coming in and like with
their fancy psychology and fancy this
and that and they thought they didn't
know what they were talking
but in this case the profile that the
FBI profilers came up with was eerily
accurate to the guy that they eventually
got serial killers almost always we're
talking in excess of [ __ ] 90% [ __ ]
serial killers always kill within their
own ethnic or racial groups yeah
that means if he's black that's yeah
that's who's that's who's doing this
well any profilers need that too because
they said if this was a white dude um
because well the victims families were
divided like some of the victims
families you know still you know we're
like yeah it's totally Williams a couple
of them were like no they don't think it
was but like I said a couple of the
cases I think are questionable still
like I think it was somebody else
however in most of the most of the emmos
like the way that the children were
taken they were usually taken in broad
daylight
um you know in neighborhoods where a lot
of people knew each other
so I feel like if it was a white dude
they would wait in the car with him he
would have been caught much earlier
because a lot of people would have been
like hey who the [ __ ] is that why do
they kill driving around like they kill
within their racial group most of the
time they kill their sexual preference
all right which means it's whatever this
guy's into he's into women or was into
boys Wayne was in he was he was into
boys yeah okay so you're talking about a
black guy who kills young black men or
young black boys and and the boys were
getting into the car with him so he is
conscious so we're talking about
somebody who's familiar somebody from
that area yeah somebody who's and
someone who doesn't stand out somebody
who's kind of trusted they know who this
guy is
yeah that's how a serial killer does it
and he has you know a ruse he has a
thing where he is actually blood promote
he has actually proof right because he
did go to I mean there was even like
there was a woman that owned a small
studio there and that and he worked
there I mean he worked there he brought
kids and he recorded them so he did do
that stuff so if people asked they said
yeah I went to this and I have recorded
a single or I did this that in the other
he had also worked with like the
local news department he did you he
didn't work for the News Agency per se
but he was like freelance he would go he
had a police scanner because he was a
police groupie like I said and he would
go to crime scenes fire Zach's car
accidents or whatever and he would film
it and then he would sell it to the
local news thing now later on he can--he
conflated that like he made it a bigger
deal like I'm a journalist and I work
for this that's not what he did he would
go and film [ __ ] but in some times he
would get there cuz he had a scanner he
would get there before the cops even got
there and he would film [ __ ] and then he
would sell it to the local news agencies
there was a white guy that had a very
similar [ __ ] gig all right he was a
fashion photographer yeah it called
himself Christopher Wilder I believe his
name was yeah and he would pick up some
of these [ __ ] just beautiful [ __ ]
white girls and yeah and take him out to
the desert for a [ __ ] sexy photoshoot
you know and they're going there
willingly take him way out into the
[ __ ] desert where there wasn't
anybody to see what the hell is going on
rape and murder him yep and bury him out
there in the damn desert yeah and he did
a lot of them that's basically what
Wayne Williams is doing he's doing he's
doing that but he's doing it to young
black guys yeah well that was tell him
he's gonna make him a star yeah and I
think that's exactly what he was doing
because some of the victims were seen
getting into the cars willingly so he
wasn't like abducting all of them by
force I think he was luring them yeah
and a stupid [ __ ] he sees me says hey
how are you doing hey you look faint are
you aren't you famous you're not a
family you're doing stupid [ __ ] like
that you should be famous I have a
record I have a whole radio station yeah
I'm looking to recruit guys for bands
you know baby that wasn't right
completely a lie because he didn't get
all the records I'm sure and he's
pulling out [ __ ] cards Bry has a
business card he's probably got a little
briefcase with [ __ ] flyers
he brought has a clipboard clipboard and
a cup of coffee make you look important
his [ __ ] you don't I mean that's what
he's doing getting a car we're gonna go
we're gonna go and I'm gonna go and
we're gonna interview you for this yeah
we're gonna do a little tryouts he was
saying
yes I'm [ __ ] like that because a lot of
these kids do you have to realize were
you know they're from poor neighborhoods
and a lot of them were like they would
do errands and [ __ ] for their
neighbors for like a couple of coins of
her buck or something like that because
even like one of the kids worked for
there was like a it was like a seafood
restaurant and the guy that owned it you
know he would let some of the
neighborhood kids he's like hey you know
I'll give you a dollar if you go to like
the [ __ ] store and get me some you
know flour or something like that so a
lot of these kids were like running
errands for pocket money you know I mean
like around the neighborhood so if Wayne
Williams pulled up to you in the car and
said hey you know can you sing or
whatever it's like you know hey I'll
give you ten bucks I'll give you twenty
bucks or something like that if you come
and like record a song then probably a
lot of them would do it yeah you know
what I mean it wouldn't seem all that
weird and he was kind of known around
the neighborhood and he actually had
recorded boys in the past so it wasn't
like he was completely making it up yeah
it's not yet it's not gonna be some kind
of outsider from that area that was a
pretty rough area you're not gonna have
these [ __ ] white dudes [ __ ] in
[ __ ] white hoods and [ __ ] like from
the Klan showing up rolling up just
grabbing some [ __ ] black kid off the
[ __ ] Road
he would scream [ __ ] bloody murder
everyone would jump out and [ __ ] stop
that down to Gators because a lot of the
investigators in the case were black as
well like even one of them that was
white was like when he was in the car
one time like with some of the other
ones like driving to some of the
neighborhoods were some of the victims
lived he's like even when he was in the
car like everybody like turn yeah yeah
why dude and he's like everybody was
like pointing at him he's like what do
they point out he's like cuz we have a
hockey in the car Yeah right like we're
doing it this way it's like so the white
dude would stand out I do definitely
believe in that and we were talking
about this we might have talked about
this a little bit in the Samuel little
show as well where I feel like the
serial killers that you know go on for
this long a time you know two years is
kind of like a long period of time and
her preying on children particularly
like in mid day and everything like that
where he's just taking them off the
street you have to be somebody that
blends into the community or people are
gonna like notice you right away yeah he
had stealth he just he was part of the
community they he was trusted yeah I
don't think anybody I think a lot of
people thought he was weird but I don't
think anybody thought he was a serial
again
you know what I mean could you ever
think that to you well I just thought he
was a gay guy if he's obviously gay yeah
to me yeah he did come it's like he
always denies it but it does really hit
come across no no no nice look at that
dude he just looks gay [ __ ] yeah sorry
yeah he does you know she's just hiding
it but he just looks like a gay dude to
me yeah you know [ __ ] but he's in an
area where he didn't walk that step he
didn't want that on him that might have
been another thing he might have been
like self-loathing is like a
self-loathing okay yeah yeah because he
didn't want that to be true and that was
all you gotta do is just see recordings
all you gotta do is just see recordings
of him back in the day with when the
news media is asking him questions
everybody's coming out of his car trying
to go into his house it's just a gay
dude sorry about it is that he really
and here's another thing too and this is
another thing the FBI profilers totally
called was that they knew that he was
gonna be like a huge attention seeking
individual now during the time period
like where he got pulled over on the
bridge cuz like I said the cops didn't
arrest him at the time because even
though they saw like a length of nylon
cord in the car that's not illegal so
there was nothing that they could do
there was nothing in the car that would
like cause them to arrest him all they
had done was heard a splash they saw his
car allegedly turn around on the bridge
and then when they stopped him he came
up with a alibi which later on they
found out was [ __ ] and then they saw
that he had like some gloves and some
nylon rope in the car which they thought
was weird but like I said it's not
illegal so during the time period where
he got stopped and was like considered a
suspect and by the time that they had
enough evidence to arrest him they had
given him a polygraph test
okay actually they gave him a series of
three polygraph tests and he failed
every single one of them now the guy
that gave the test there was an
interview with him on the CNN thing and
he said that he's like basically I just
asked him like very straightforward
questions he said he was very interested
in the polygraph test and asked me like
you know what are you gonna ask me he's
like I usually like tell you what I'm
gonna ask you like before I even give
you the test so you're like prepared for
it and he's like so you know did you
dump this guy off the you know did you
dump Nathaniel cater off the bridge did
you kill
you know the regular questions you would
have and he's like I feel like so he
failed like every single one of the
questions there was like three major
questions he failed it was they gave him
the test three times he failed all three
times and he said the funniest thing was
that Wayne Williams seen Jim seemed
genuinely shocked that he could not beat
the polygraph test I think that because
he was a police junky and he was super
into law enforcement and it read all
this [ __ ] about it and like I said later
he was dead Sienna yeah so I think that
he thought oh I can beat a polygraph
test yeah he must and he was like
surprised that he failed like everything
must have read oh [ __ ] something
about how to beat a polygraph saying I
think he read that exactly cuz there are
some there are some stuff out there well
if you say it you believe it you'll beat
it yeah the thing is though is that
polygraph over the tip I used to think
that polygraph was [ __ ] like end-all
to be all now and most of it has that to
rule people out it's not admissible
holly / we had polygraph really has to
do with the interpretation of the data
some people can interpret it in in a
couple different ways
although okay here's no here's a better
way to put that some people are good at
running a polygraph yeah on another
person other people are kind of shitty
at it is that is that a good way to put
it yeah because there are some people
that pass polygraphs that I'm thinking I
think the interpretation of funniness
all that the polygraph measures is
essentially stress stress and if you
were a complete psychopath who may not
have access when you lie then you might
not have any stress most people do
though and I feel like wait but as I
said polygraphs are not super accurate
and that's why they are not I mean at
least in the United States I don't know
about other countries in the United
States they're not admissible in a court
of law the only thing that they use them
for is ruling people out essentially
like if you are brought in and they kind
of think maybe you did something or you
know something and they give you a
polygraph and you pass
sit and it's fine and everything they're
like okay well they probably don't know
anything about it they just like use it
to rule people out so they gave him like
I said they gave him every opportunity
they gave him three separate polygraph
test and he failed all of them and the
guy that administered them said that he
seems really surprised that he had
failed them and like you said I think
that he had read a very specific book
about how to pass the polygraph test and
I think he thought that he would be able
to do it but he couldn't do it is there
some case that it was very obvious there
are some cases that where guys have
passed polygraphs yeah but that case is
awful fishy yeah okay when I'm thinking
about a UFO case remember when all those
guys passed that damn polygraph test
I can Travis Walton case yeah if they
passed that case the guys everybody the
guy who administered that test said they
all passed that test with flying colors
yeah which means that the do was
abducted by UFOs okay or those guys
thought that yeah but the gun Travis
went up there and saw all kinds of
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] that I'm like called
[ __ ] all myself I'm like dude man
extraterrestrials wouldn't that wouldn't
really do that I don't thank you I mean
I just I just think it's no I'm just not
gonna it's not gonna the Travis Walton
case I think is far [ __ ] it out well the
thing is though if you saw okay let's
say this happened let's say that you had
this really really vivid dream okay
or hallucination that to your mind
really happens like you could or you
couldn't determine if it really happen
here if you dreamed it and then if
somebody gave you a polygraph about it
then maybe you would pass the polygraph
because to you it's like maybe it did
happen because you couldn't discern
certain elements of Travis's story just
[ __ ] sound too outlandish to me but
other people did see him being abducted
by a damn alien spacecraft
yeah and they pulled out like I said
they thought they or at least they
thought they saw that I don't know what
at the time that [ __ ] happened I don't
think humans could [ __ ] make a craft
that they described they they said that
[ __ ] was alien I don't know man that's
just [ __ ] getting bizarre I did what
I do believe in extraterrestrials I do
because there has to be asked of
terrestrials of course I mean
the universe is huge some of those UFO
cases [ __ ] man I'm getting back on
UFOs but yeah some of those cases UFO
cases are [ __ ] very [ __ ] important
you know I mean thinking Jets you know
[ __ ] US military jet pilots seeing
weird [ __ ] the [ __ ] Pentagon backing
them up I've seen the [ __ ] videos the
little dots [ __ ] flying around
there's something out there but being
abducted yeah I don't know just I'm not
so sure about polygraph though well I
don't think anyone is and I'm just
saying that it's significant that he
thought he could pass but he didn't pass
oh yeah what he read it how do you had a
beat polygraph yeah yeah they're harder
to beat you think but I'm not sure a lot
of the [ __ ] that they measure is not
under your control necessarily like
depending on the person but like I said
I don't think they're entirely accurate
it's not the vent and I think a lot of
it usually it's like I said the only
thing they use it for uk it's not
admissible in a court of law you can't
even bring it up it's not in any state
in the Union as far as I know the only
thing they use it for is very early on
in the investigation when they're
bringing people in that they think are
suspects maybe this person knows
something about it maybe they don't and
they just want to be able to rule people
out because if you can easily pass you
don't seem stressed out and they ask you
about it they say well you probably
don't know anything or you probably
don't know anything so they just use it
to rule people out and like narrow down
on who they think they're really so
really it so goes back to what I was
saying before it depends on who's
administering this [ __ ] with the
question that they like everything else
so there's a chance that a dude who's a
quack could administer a [ __ ]
polygraph test and come up with a
[ __ ] incorrect result yeah I mean
some of it might depend on the questions
they ask and [ __ ] like that too but I
mean the monitors like measure [ __ ] I
mean whatever yeah you know what I mean
but it really did seem at least the guy
that administered this for these
particular tests was like it was very
obvious that he was very nervous that
Wayne Williams is very nervous
when they ask mr. and then she was lying
I'm sure he was lying like is he said he
just looked at it was like oh okay well
yeah I'm sure Wayne Williams was lying
yeah I'm just think about the UFO guys
yeah but good well that yeah no I'm sure
he's lying because [ __ ] they arrested
his ass yeah and the [ __ ] murders
stopped yeah and yeah he fits he fits
the bill perfectly that's him yeah it
was out there near a body dump yeah I
mean even though he said he had I mean
even just the fact that he [ __ ] lied
about it what he was doing out there
obviously because they never defined
this like mysterious yeah nonexistent
have you ever known me to get in the car
and [ __ ] drive out to a remote area
for just sitting around a bridge yeah no
no that's right that's not normal
behavior no I'm just saying you can't
like you know say the dudes a murderer
just because of that but there were like
a ton of other things that added up
because I feel like a few of the people
that said like maybe he was innocent of
all the crimes which i think is kind of
a small percentage but or be like well
you know yeah he did this and yeah he
did that but it's like you know you
can't it's all circumstantial I'm like
yeah but there's a point where there's
so much circumstantial evidence that
it's really unlikely that it was
somebody else
you know what I mean it's just kind of
like yeah standing on a bridge in the
middle of the night is not near where a
body was done there where a body was
done and the body came from where you
use somebody just for that however if
say for example as in the Wayne Williams
case they found carpet fibers on at
least five of the bodies that matched
carpet that was in his house
they also found yellow fibers from a
blanket that was found in his house
although he allegedly got rid of it in
between the first police search on the
second police search of the house so I
don't know how that went
they also found dog hairs on some of the
victims that were similar to dog hairs
of his dog whose name was Sheba a German
Shepherd I think so it's kind of like
there was like a conflation you know and
there were several witnesses that placed
him with you know being seen with some
of the victims particularly in the
Fanueil cater like before they died
and you know there was just it was a
bunch of little [ __ ] but it just added
up to like bigger [ __ ] you know what I
mean
that's hammy dude that's that's what I'm
saying and you know it should be said
that like I said he was only convicted
of two but you know tellingly they
closed 23 of the 29 cases after saying
well he probably did them we don't want
to go through all the money and all the
heartbreak of like doing trials for all
of these victims because they figured
that he probably did them and case
closed there are any other happen but in
the past when they have arrested the
wrong man
the murders continued yeah that's just
telling yeah he was arrested and the
murder stopped but what I was gonna say
like about the FBI saying about him
being attention-seeking so after they
brought him in and they did the
polygraph and then they let him go back
to his house which was also his parents
house the thing the first thing that he
did the next day was he called a press
conference I remember that I saw that
and he wouldn't let them show his face
yeah now he did admit to all the press
because they're still footage of it like
you can see it it's on YouTube and
everything he wouldn't let them put his
face on camera but he did admit that he
had failed the polygraph test but he's
like you know they want me for this and
he was started he started like putting
forward the narrative that he was just
like a scapegoat you know what I mean
that it's like I just happened to be
like in this place and you know at the
wrong time and they kind of got me for
all these crimes and there was a little
bit of a thing to where he's like well
they don't want it to be a black man so
I you know or they didn't want it to be
a white man because you know they did
they're pinning it on me instead even
though I kind of feel like that wasn't
the case like I said I don't I don't
necessarily believe that he killed all
29 of the black investigators knew it
was the black guy well yeah and one of
the guys on the documentary even said
yeah that same thing because they hunt
within their [ __ ] racial group most
of the time they do there there have
been a few serial killers that have gone
outside there that have killed like most
people of multiple races there yeah it's
been particularly serious some
[ __ ] want variety
well serial killers particularly the
target like prostitutes yeah right well
usually not it just depends on what that
what what what is acceptable except
what's accessible and that's really what
victim profiles but yes so as I said on
several of the victims they had found
you know dog hairs fibers from carpet
please you know cuz they took a lot of
[ __ ] from from Wayne Williams house his
parents house now one thing that a lot
of neighbors said was that after the
police had come there and taken a bunch
of [ __ ] from the house like the carpet
you know the you know bits of the carpet
and bits of the blankets and the
comforter and all this other kind of
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] from his car which
also matched some of the fibers found on
the bodies as well allegedly some of the
neighbors said that the day after the
first police search that Wayne Williams
and his dad were out in the back burning
a bunch of stuff like in the grill out
back so allegedly I'm just saying
and another thing too and Soledad
O'Brien brought this up when she was
interviewing him was that you know they
found all these yellow fibers that were
supposedly from this blanket that was at
his house and he's just like well the
blankets not there now and she's like
yeah cos probably destroyed it like in
between the first search of the second
one and he's like well you can't say
that there was no yellow blank it's like
he kept saying stuff like like he never
said I don't think he ever came you know
he would come out right and say like oh
I never killed anybody but he would
always kind of freeze it like nobody
ever saw me hurting anybody nobody ever
saw me killing anybody it's like and I
just found it weird that he phrased it
like that almost kind of like well you
can't prove it
you're not that he didn't do it but they
trying to prove it he's trying to take a
legalistic approach that just sounds
like to me so she's like being evasive
well yeah yeah but also understand he's
doing he's saying we try to convict me
on things you have evidence for right
that's what he's doing but he knows that
there's no evidence because he was there
yeah you didn't see me do this I did but
you need to see we do it you weren't
there that's what I mean that was very
like instructive that even this many
years later you know in 2010 he's still
saying no one saw me do this no one saw
me that's what he was saying like and
later he would say oh I didn't kill
anybody but the fact that he said that
like right out the gate that just sounds
like a very weird way
freeze it if you were innocent is one of
the thing it is weird yeah so he goes to
trial now the you know they decided to
only go after him for the two murders of
you know two of the older victims
because that's what they had the most
evidence for however one thing that they
did allow the prosecution to do which
they do in some cases I'm not sure how
all states operate but in Georgia it was
apparently this you could introduce
evidence from the other murders if you
could prove that there was enough
evidence that there was like a pattern
there you know I mean even though he
wasn't technically on trial for these
other like five or six murders of the
children you know what I mean that that
they were that they had like you know a
pretty solid case for they're like well
he's not being charged with those but
you can introduce evidence from that
just because you're establishing a
pattern you know what I mean even though
he's not being convicted in them so they
did allow them to do that there were
five or six other cases where they
allowed them to you know introduce
evidence for that it might have been as
many as 12 I'm not really sure but so
they dramatized some of the trial or
most of the trial in the [ __ ] 1985
thing that I watched and it you know
that some people said this some people
said that some people said they saw
Wayne some people said they saw another
dude it's like there was like two or
three different cars bill said they saw
a brown Cadillac some it was a white
station wagon which is what we what what
he had so like I said it's not out of
the bounds of possibility that there
might have been he might have had an
accomplice or there might have been like
a pedophile ring you know that's not
totally weird it's not out of the bounds
I find it unlikely though it's probably
unlikely I mean I don't think he would
have shared yeah yeah maybe not I I do
think that there was another killer
running around though I think at least
like the female victims that were
probably killer I think that was another
killer I think Wayne Williams was very
private yeah about what he was doing
yeah I don't think he would have shared
with another killer and I think he was
embarrassed about what he was doing he
didn't even want to be known as being
gay yeah that's what I think
yes I think you really wouldn't admit
that even though some people said that
they had seen him like sizing men yes or
I think he's doing everything on the
down-low this is a kind of a dark secret
yeah I think so yeah that's my take on
him so even though so what ended up
happening at the trial was that even
though um his defense team strongly
suggested that he not testify on his own
behalf
now the weird thing was that though most
of the time that he was in police
custody he pretty much kept his cool he
was just very you know cool he would
like just you you know he was very
adamant about being innocent but he
didn't like lose his cool or anything
like that however some of the
prosecution were like well if you keep
needling him he seems like the type of
person that will eventually blow up and
that's what we need him to do because we
want the jury to see because as it as it
was he came across as very mild-mannered
he didn't come across as a killer but
they said if he loses his temper and
flips out on the stand then everybody
will see you know that side of him and
it will be like really damaging and
indeed that is exactly what happened and
she [ __ ] little [ __ ] he went
he got on the stand and the prosecutor
just kept like needling him and needling
him because he knew that eventually he
was gonna lose it and he did um so he
basically said you want to see the real
wayne wood this is him and he's like
freaking out and a lot of the jury
members later they talked to a couple
jury members on that documentary one of
them said the fiber evidence had been
like a huge thing because the fiber that
they found particularly the one from the
green carpet that had been in his house
was very unusual like the pattern of it
like under the microscope was a very
strange like you know it wasn't like a
real widespread kind of carpet so the
fact that they had found it on I believe
five of the victims and they found it in
his bedroom of his house as well you
know whose astronomically he said the
odds were a strongly against that
however a lot of jury members said that
one of the things that push them toward
conviction because it only took them 11
hours to find him guilty at least the
two murders he was being charged with
was the fact that he had just like lost
it like on the stand and they could and
they could see that this is the person
that because before they said they
couldn't really see it because he seemed
very like meek and mild and he didn't
really seem like somebody that could
kill somebody because he wasn't real big
it wasn't intimidating and a lot of
these victims had been strangled and
some of them had strangled like in
headlock type of thing like he'd put him
like in their heads like that like in
his elbow and the crook of his elbow and
he would strangle him like that and so a
lot of people didn't think that he would
be strong enough to do that although
they did have a lot of people testify he
was a lot stronger like physically
stronger than he looked
he also said later I don't know this is
probably not true but he did say later
on that he had learned some CIA hand
hand combat techniques that later
I have a friend him and Frank do this
spraying together a train together he
went to the kumite yeah I guess yeah
VanDam was there yeah yes but yeah so so
the fact that he like lost his [ __ ] on
the stand was one of the things that
probably got him convicted and he
actually seems to acknowledge that
because in a 2010 interview he said that
when he lost it he said I'm my own worst
enemy he's like I could he's like
because I could see it as soon as I lost
my temper I could see it in the jurors
faces that they were like oh this is the
dude because this is the side of him and
they haven't seen it yet so I guess his
defense team were right and saying yeah
you shouldn't get your ass on the stand
but he did he insisted and that's what
ended up happening um but like I said I
don't see that as a bad thing because
he's probably the [ __ ] that did
all this stuff so he did it so so I
don't think that was such a good thing I
think it was a good thing that he got
caught but now so a lot of the families
like I said we're kind of pissed that
they never really did bring any like
formal charges and in any of the child
murders because essentially even though
they consider 23 of them solved because
they think well he did them even though
he didn't really get formally charged or
convicted of them some of the families
still think that maybe he didn't do it
and maybe there was another killer
running around out there in a couple of
the
cases I do think they're probably right
because like I said I think particularly
the girls and stuff I think that was
someone else but I do think Wayne
Williams was probably rightfully I mean
I've those 23 cases that were all that
similar I think those were all probably
him whether he had an accomplice or not
I don't know but I do think he was
involved in those 23 is a big number but
that's actually very reasonable for a
guy like this yeah a dude who looks and
acts basically normal can get that many
yeah totally there for a two years over
- yeah and [ __ ] we know we've talked
about other killers on this program that
have [ __ ] racked up scores like that
just yeah only in a few years
having a good ruse and looking harmless
helps a lot oh yeah so I think that I
think that's him I think it is - and um
you know the FBI profilers you know like
I said even though there was [ __ ] later
on with a lot of the [ __ ] that came out
about like the KKK where you know at
least some of the day at least recorded
some phone calls around the time period
where at least one of the members was
saying he didn't say that he had done
the crimes but he was happy that they
were being done because it was wiping
out future generations of n-words
yeah um you know he he did say that on
the phone call also there was another
thing another phone call where one of
them said to another one you want me to
go get you another kid which they
thought was fishy so they did so the FBI
did look into that angle but they
couldn't really find any evidence like
any physical evidence like tying them to
the case we got to do a show about the
Klan one of these days about the whole
history of the Klan yeah it is it would
make an interesting [ __ ] it probably
would there isn't one Klan a lot of
people think there's a lot people today
think there's one Klan and it's one long
continuous Klan there were three clans
really the original clan and then the
Klan the Depression era clan then it
ended up ending later on like in the
[ __ ] 50s and then there's like the
modern Klan and they were vol very very
different
some some of them were organized
and some of them just aren't but that
that's for a different show though yeah
you can't just put anything on the Klan
as if the Klan is kind of like one big
organization it just it just isn't
anymore
it hasn't been for a long time it's just
a boogeyman that people try to well I
mean in the 50s and 60s because I wrote
about it it was there my book yeah they
did a bunch of but then they admitted
the [ __ ] well they have a steering in
time where it was kind of like political
terrorism yes exactly but but they
killed like black sheriff yeah
but the Klan that the modern version of
the Klan is not that it's it's it's
[ __ ] yeah well it's not like a it's
not like it's not a monolithic no it's
not organized it's not so & L's and
another thing I was saying is that the
modern Klan is poor there was just that
makes a huge difference yeah
the original client had nothing to do
with say the Depression era Klan between
the 20s and the 50s and the 60s that
actually was the what they would call
the invisible Empire
it actually was something you know I
mean there it did happen there was
something to it then but that's gone
that's gone now and it had to do with
the fact that the dam leader he got if I
couldn't arrested for rape you know I
mean if I can you know I mean and the
guy who's behind it was a scam even back
then it was a money scam yeah but you
just can't lay it all at the feet of
[ __ ] some at the Klan yeah I mean I
do that I can see why the community
would think that yeah because it's not
like that was completely unfounded but
it in this case it really does seem like
now even um John Douglas the profiler
who you know one of the characters in my
header was based on he says that he does
believe that Wayne Williams is guilty of
most of the murders but not all of them
not of the weather or more than one
killer out there yeah and like I said I
think there were a couple that were
probably not him now
Williams has this whole entire time
obviously protested his innocence and
has consistently tried to get retrials
and is like always bringing up new [ __ ]
like trying to get new evidence like
trying to get new DN
other kind of stuff to get a retrial to
see what what happened so in 2007 they
actually agreed and they decided to do
some DNA on the dog hairs that have been
found on some of the bodies because like
I said the dog hairs at the time and the
ATS had been considered very similar to
you know Wayne Williams's dog but they
didn't have like the technology to like
make an exacting kind of thing so he
kind of pushed for that they did that
and they found out that they could only
do mitochondrial DNA on the dog and they
found out that even though it wasn't
certain that it was the same dog because
it wasn't like precise enough they did
say that the mitochondrial DNA sequence
that they found was only happened in one
in 100 dogs so odds are it was probably
Wayne Williams's dog later on in that
year they also found some human hairs
that had been found on some of the
victims
now these human hairs was only two of
them so they did DNA on that the
mitochondrial DNA sequence in the hairs
eliminate would eliminate 99.5 percent
of people whose DNA did not match now
the mitochondrial DNA sequence in the
hairs would also eliminate 98% of
African American persons by not matching
their DNA however they did match
Williams's DNA and a Wyoming it wasn't a
hundred percent but it was like this
damn it it's like really really
brilliantly unlikely that it wasn't his
hair yeah it's possible but very very
very unlikely yeah now that you bring
that up cuz now yeah I understand the
statistics that they're talking about
there yeah because Wayne Williams
probably could be identified almost as
biracial he was very light-skinned he
was yeah so that eliminates a lot of
people it was him I think it was - yeah
um they are actually as of March of 2019
they have said that they're going to
retest some of the evidence to see if
there were any other killers you know
what I mean like if there was anything
left to be tested to see if there was
anything else to do I haven't heard
anything else in that arena
should say to that one of the guys who
was on Wayne Williams's defense team he
later wrote a book about the canonical
list that all the victims were put on
and he was pointing out that you know a
lot of victims that were left off the
list probably should have been on there
and some of the ones that were on there
shouldn't been on there it's like you
know what I mean they he said that the
the rules for putting them on the list
were kind of arbitrary at the time now
one thing that I found was kind of
interesting because remember um you know
the case of angel lunaire who was 12 and
she was found like you know with her
hands tied behind her back like you know
tied to a tree or whatever um it should
be noted that nine months after that
happened there was another crime almost
exactly like that in Atlanta and the
victim's name was Fay year b-but she was
22
now she was found almost exactly the
same way hands tied behind her back like
tied to a tree she'd been sexually
assaulted and [ __ ] like that but they
didn't put her on the list because they
thought at the time well she's too old
because this was before Wayne Williams
had started killing the older men so
they were leaving off victims that were
of that age verbs they only incorporated
older victims like once that started
happening in the series so since this
was before that they said oh well this
girl was too old so it's obviously not
the same killer but do I think that he
killed figure B no I do think that the
same person that killed Angela Nair who
was probably not Wayne Williams killed
failure B as well because that's very
very that's a very specific signature
and around the same time and I think
that was a different dude
because usually like I said it's not
impossible I have heard of some serial
killers that kill like particularly
pedophilic ones that will kill both boys
and girls but it's unusual it's unusual
usually they'll target one of the other
and I feel like since the vast majority
and the victims were boys or young men
the fact that there were a couple female
victims in there that makes me think
that that was somebody else yeah I think
that was somebody I agree but um you
know I'm not certain but in my opinion I
statistics yes to tist eclis it would
know wouldn't be him I think that was
another Sarah
he is killing boys and young men that's
what he does
yeah that seems like his thing and he's
killing he killed them in a different
way and like he would leave their bodies
in different types of areas I just think
it was a different signature that's all
but yes so um I think that's probably
about it on the case you're probably you
seem like you're getting
yeah I'm pretty focused nockard oh hold
on people it's not even that late there
was a lot of alcohol that I drank though
it was yeah I only had one I didn't even
get a refill on it
I'll get you one okay but yeah so
seriously absolutely I haven't seen the
HBO series so maybe there's some [ __ ] we
didn't go into on that but you know I
did see like all of the other
documentaries about like the older ones
and I watch like they're really older
than from 1985 which is actually pretty
entertaining it's on YouTube it's a kind
of like a bunch of famous people in it
like I said dad from hellraisers in it
and everything he plays like an attorney
I was like cracking up going in it that
day now I'm glad we got to this kid his
case cuz some black dudes that I know
they just don't want to [ __ ] accept
it Wayne Williams was the one that did
it but know that if you understand
serial killers that was him man they got
him yeah I think like I said I don't
think he did every single one on that
little murder she did that I think he
did most of them yeah yeah all the ones
that were like the same like
strangulation dumped to the woods all
that kind of stuff I think yeah but like
I said I do think there's another killer
running around that killed some of the
other people that probably still need to
catch so they should probably get on
that but yeah so I guess we're gonna
wrap it up because it's getting kind of
late
we're getting kind of drunk and tired
it's Friday night we're recording this
yeah we want to kind of go entertain
ourselves in other ways so hope you guys
you like that yeah I'm going to I'm like
a baby all right we're wrapping up
episode 195 about the depressing topic
for the Atlanta child murders even
we next shows got to be fun though it
will be hey we'll do a fun one these
[ __ ] practic that's just funny as
sick as they are anyway but forget I
like a good paranormal case well not
necessarily paranormal where we doing
next with what's gonna hang up man we're
probably gonna do boy you want to do
that strong man thing strong me yeah
yeah yeah probably
okay you keep bugging me about how you
know you had that on the list already
okay well yeah I stuck it on there cuz I
said well I gotta put this on here so
tamil stop like complaining about it
yeah next week next week we're gonna do
like the [ __ ] origins of [ __ ]
strong men we're gonna do Eugene Sandow
probably Pandora and we're gonna talk
about you're gonna have all kind of fun
on that yeah talk about [ __ ] we're
gonna talk about [ __ ] steroids we'll
talk about all that [ __ ] yes yeah yes
that won't be fun at ease versus fight
isn't depressing yeah yeah Nattie's
versus [ __ ] you know [ __ ] enhanced
we're gonna talk about super human
[ __ ] imma call [ __ ] on
stuff and I'm gonna yeah I gotta call
[ __ ] on certain thing all these feet
daddy's running around yeah listen
natural dudes I know but that's that
[ __ ] shitty beer also yeah and pride
people probably wondering is that mother
[ __ ] natural is Tom natural imma
answer that question next week a little
natural it's a stop [ __ ] natural
we'll find out it's a [ __ ] clip
remember if you like the show if you
like the show like share subscribe on
all your social media it really does
help us out a lot you know if you want
to financially supports show
that'd be really awesome just like all
of our wonderful people that we shouted
out at the beginning of the show you can
do that as well and go to our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a button in the sidebar that
goes to a PayPal account that goes right
to ours ours truly I was gonna say yours
truly and but also you so you know if
you want to do that you can do that as
well and that'll do it for episode 195
we will see you next time
by
[Music]
you
[Music]